öffnet war eintritt in die tagesordnung
gerade lirich nachträglich der kollegin
franziska kinder zum 76 geburtstag und
dem kollegen ernst dieter rossmann zum
siebzigsten geburtstag im namen des
ganzen hauses will sich in beiden alles
gute
das neue lebensjahr auf verlangen der
fraktion der afd wird nach den ohne
debatte punkten eine aktuelle stunde zum
thema neutralität der wissenschaft
bewahren politischen drucker
forschungsinstitute verhindern
aufgesetzt und jetzt rufe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 5 abgabe einer
regierungserklärung durch die
bundeskanzlerin zur bewältigung der
kurve 19
für die aussprache im anschluss an die
regierungserklärung eine dauer von 90
minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne ich eröffne gar nichts
natürlicher teil der bund sein
das wort zur abgabe der
regierungserklärung
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren es ist nun schon mehr als ein
jahr
dass wir in dieser pandemie leben mehr
als ein jahr
dass der größte teil meiner arbeit als
bundeskanzlerin der arbeit der
bundesregierung der des bundestages der
landesregierung der landtage der
kreistage und verwaltung mit dieser
einen aufgabe zu tun hat unser land
durch diese katastrophe und wieder in
bessere zeiten zu führen
seit dem ausbruch der pandemie stemmen
wir uns alle gemeinsam gegen das virus
es ist eine wirkliche nationale
kraftanstrengung die jeden erfasst und
die jeden betrifft
alte wie junge und kinder stadt und land
politik verwaltung bildung wirtschaft
kultur sport kirchen unser aller leben
und zusammenleben
es ist ein jahr in dem wir gemeinsam
gelernt haben wie das virus funktioniert
und was gegen das virus funktioniert
lernen heißt nicht von anfang an immer
alles richtig zu machen
auch einschätzungen zu korrigieren so
wie wir es zum beispiel bei den
empfehlungen für das tragen von masken
getan haben aber gerade deswegen sage
ich auch wenn wir gerade in einer
schwierigen phase stecken und viele
menschen das gefühl haben das wirklich
nicht mehr lange auszuhalten
gerade deswegen sage ich auch wir haben
in diesem jahr der pandemie ein sehr
großes stück des so schweren weges
hinter uns gebracht
um dabei hatten und haben wir das ziel
unserer gesundheit unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
höchstbelastung der menschen und der
kapazitäten in den intensiv medizin
ja sie gab es und gibt es leider
und wir können unseren ärzten und ärzten
und pflegerinnen und pflegern gar nicht
oft genug für all ihren einsatz danken
aber eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems die konnten wir
vermeiden
gott sei dank wer mit schweren folgen
einer corona infektion in die klinik
muss der bekommt überall in deutschland
die versorgung die er braucht wir sehen
an vielen orten der welt wie wenig
selbstverständlich diese aussage ist und
wir können gemeinsam froh darüber sein
dabei weiß ich dass das was wir
gemeinsam im kampf gegen die ausbreitung
des virus erreicht haben einen hohen
preis gekostet hat und unverändert
kostet ich vergesse keinen einzigen tag
was die notwendigen maßnahmen für jeden
bürger jede bürgerin bedeuten eine in
der bundesrepublik so nie erlebte
zeitweilige gravierende einschränkung
der freiheit schwere persönliche
belastungen einsamkeit wirtschaftliche
sorgen existenzängste das vergesse ich
keinen einzigen tag
alle maßnahmen sind gemäss den regeln
unserer demokratie beschlossen worden
das macht das rechtmäßig aber ich weiß
sehr wohl als demokratie sind wir auch
verpflichtet diese einschränkungen
keinen tag länger aufrecht zu erhalten
als nötig und sie aufzuheben wenn ihre
begründung entfällt und genau das ist
das ziel der bundesregierung und ich
weiß auch des ganzen deutschen bundestag
meine damen und herren ich brauch von
dem was wir gemeinsam erreicht haben
dazu gehört dass die erste welle der
pandemie im frühjahr 2020 deutschland
weit weniger hart getroffen hat als
viele andere in europa und weltweit
dem folgte ein sommer in dem wir im
rückblick gesehen wieder leichter leben
konnten bei instanzen die heute
traumhaft erscheinen drei oder vier
ansteckungen über sieben tage auf 100000
einwohnern dann und das müssen wir zu
den leben zählen dann waren wir nicht
vorsichtig genug und nicht schnell genug
wir haben auf die anzeichen der zweiten
welle und die warnungen verschiedener
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hin nicht früh und nicht konsequent
genug
das öffentliche leben wieder
heruntergefahren bei meiner letzten
regierungserklärung hier vor ihnen das
war am 26 november 2020 hatten wir
wochen dramatischen exponentiellen
wachstums der infektionszahlen hinter
uns diese steile wachstum haben wir
schließlich beenden können aber noch bis
in den januar dieses jahres hinein
verbreitet sich das virus viel zu
schnell und viel zu unkontrolliert eine
folge dessen bin ich sicher von
zögerlichen vorgehen ausgangs des
sommers und im herbst
heute stehen wir dass die
infektionszahlen angelangt weit besser
da die notwendige trendumkehr die ich am
26 november erhofft hatte ist gelungen
die zahl der neuinfektionen seit
geraumer zeit zurück ebenso die zahl der
aktiven corona fälle und die zahl der
koma patientin in den intensivstationen
und in aller vorsicht sage ich auch die
schlimmste die traurigste zahl von allen
die der menschen die jeden tag an corona
sterben scheint endlich wieder zu sinken
wenigstens werden keine neuen
höchststände mehr erreicht diese
verstorbenen es sind jetzt weit mehr als
60.000 menschen das sind unsere mütter
väter kinder verwandte freunde die wir
nicht bewahren konnten die trauer um sie
und mit ihrem hinterbliebenen steht
immer im raum wenn wir entscheidungen in
dieser pandemie treffen das sind wir
ihnen schuldig
dann gibt es noch eine positive
entwicklung auf die bei meiner letzten
regierungserklärung nur hoffen konnte
die aber keineswegs gewiss war
die impfstoffe sind da das ist ein
wendepunkt in der pandemie er wurde dank
der arbeit fantastischer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in rekordgeschwindigkeit erreicht wir
haben uns für den europäischen weg der
verhandlungen der beschaffung wird der
verteilung der impfstoffe und gegen nur
zulassungen entschieden
dazu stehe ich in der schwersten krise
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg halten wir
europäer zusammen politisch wie auch
epidemiologisch überall in der
europäischen union wird jetzt geimpft
kein kleines oder wirtschaftsschwäche
russland muss sich hinten anstellen der
einsatz europäischer mittel wie auch die
abnahmegarantien die deutschland
übernommen hat hat im übrigen bei antec
zb den einstieg in die massenproduktion
seines impfstoffs ermöglicht natürlich
meine damen und herren verstehe ich dass
der start der impfkampagne in
deutschland gleichwohl zunächst viele
menschen enttäuscht denn die hoffnungen
die am impfen hängen sind riesig und
jeder von uns und auch ich haben doch
diese hoffnung auch ganz persönlich wenn
dann am antrag zwar ein zugesagter menge
aber gleichwohl nur verhältnismäßig
wenige dosen
verstehen müssen sehr schwerwiegende
entscheidungen getroffen werden
bei ihnen helfen die empfehlungen der
ständigen impfkommission
auf ihrer grundlage haben wir
entschieden zuerst die verletzlichsten
und gefährdeten zu impfen die alten
menschen im pflege- und sonstigen
einrichtungen sowie die ärzte und
pflegekräfte die sich um sie und um die
korona patienten kümmert kümmern
heute haben mehr als 80 prozent aller
menschen in pflegeheimen und weit über
eine million menschen in medizin und
pflege mindestens ihre erste impfung
bekommen dass es überaus wichtig und das
bedeutet schutz wo er am allernötigsten
gebraucht wird jede woche jeden monat
werden nun millionen weitere impfdosen
bringen und immer mehr menschen werden
diesen schutz bekommen und bis zum ende
des sommers jeder der möchte dieses ziel
wollen wir angesichts der uns zugesagten
mengen an impfstoffen und zwar an
impfstoffen führen schon zugelassenen
produzenten auch erreichen und es bleibt
natürlich auch weiterhin ganz klar so
wie die bundesregierung sich zu beginn
der verhandlung mit den
impfstoffherstellern finanziell
engagiert hat zu werden wir sie auch
weiterhin dabei unterstützen wo immer
das möglich ist neue produktionsstätten
zu finden und die produktion weiter hoch
zu fahren was von ganz besonderer
bedeutung auch im blick auf die
mutationen ist gestern hat biontech die
impfstoffproduktion in marburg gestartet
die bundesregierung hat eine task force
gebildet zu den fragen des impfens die
auch beständig tagen wird das impfen
kommt also immer mehr in schwung die
infektionszahlen sind auf dem weg nach
unten andere wichtige indikatoren auch
und wenn das das ganze bild wäre dann
sehen sie mich hier heute recht
zuversichtlich bei allen schwierigkeiten
da ist aber es war nichts war zwar noch
nicht ganz sichtbar aber immer
erkennbarer
eine große gefahr für diesen guten weg
auf dem wir uns befinden und das ist
eine sehr reale gefahr in form
mutationen des virus die sich gebildet
haben und zwar so gebildet haben dass
sie zu aggressiveren virusvarianten
geführt haben
es waren natürlich irgendwann damit zu
rechnen und es kann auch in zukunft
weitere unerfreuliche entwicklung gehen
jetzt haben wir es mit im wesentlichen
drei relevanten mutation zu tun der
englischen bei uns am weitesten
verbreitet der südafrikanischen der
brasilianischen noch ist nicht alles aus
erforscht aber wir tun gut daran an den
annahmen viele expertinnen und experten
aus dem in und ausland nicht zu zweifeln
wenn sie uns erklären alle drei
mutationen sind deutlich aggressiver
also ansteckender übertragen sich
leichter als das ursprungsvirus und wie
es bei deren ist die mutanten setzten
sich aufgrund genau diese eigenschaften
früher oder später gegen die vorherige
warnte durch
so ist das in einigen europäischen
ländern bereits geschehen
die daraufhin eine zeitweilig
dramatische zunahme an infektionsfällen
erlebten mit allen katastrophalen
auswirkungen auf die gesundheitssysteme
diese mutationen sind inzwischen auch in
deutschland nachgewiesen worden in der
letzten januarwoche sind haben einen
teil von 5,7 prozent ein
wir werden in den nächsten tagen neue
daten bekommen
am häufigsten kommt bei uns die
englische variante vor expertinnen und
experten erklären uns dass es eben nur
eine frage der zeit sein bis diese
mutationen dann auch die oberhand
gewinnen und das ursprungsvirus
verdrängen und darauf müssen wir uns
einstellen
trotz sinkender instanzen die wir im
augenblick haben müssen wir einfach
wissen dass sich darunter eine neue
virusvariante aufbaut und das wir sehr
sehr achtsam sein müssen nicht immer
weiter nicht wieder ins exponentielle
war
hinzu kommen deshalb deshalb mag ja sein
dass es irgendwie es gefällt aber wir
müssen mit der realität leben und dann
auch die richtigen antworten will was
hilft uns dabei wir haben eine situation
in der die impfkampagne immer schneller
an läuft aber sie wird uns in den
nächsten monaten noch nicht den
gemeinschafts schutz bieten sondern nur
individuellen schutz den wir brauchen
die erwartungen vieler menschen ist
natürlich dass jetzt wieder die zeit sei
einen klaren weg von öffnungen und
erleichterungen aufzuzeigen und wir
wissen dass die gefahr der mutationen
uns die erfolge wieder kaputt machen
können indem eben die höheren erwehrte
uns in ein exponentielles wachstum
zurückfallen lassen
das ist die ausgangssituation vor der
wir gestern zusammen gekommen sind und
und länder und wir haben alle gemeinsam
diese schwierige widersprüchliche lage
empfunden und wir haben vor diesem
hintergrund maßnahmen vereinbart und
zwar bis zum 7 märz die allermeisten der
beschränkenden maßnahmen müssen
konsequent beibehalten werden es geht
immer und immer wieder um die
reduzierung von kontakten in dem wir
private zusammenkünfte auf den eigenen
hausstand und eine weitere person
beschränken indem wir medizinische
masken die jetzt möglicherweise
ausreichend vorhanden sind tragen und
zwar in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln in
geschäften in innenräumen wie hier im
deutschen bundestag und das gilt auch
für die arbeitswelt zu fern mehr als
eine person im raum ist privatreisen und
besucher auch von verwandten sind weiter
zu unterlassen und das arbeiten im home
office muss wo immer möglich
durchgesetzt werden und ich will noch
einmal an die arbeitgeberinnen
arbeitgeber wirklich appellieren das ist
ein probates mittel um
takte zu reduzieren die privat die
privaten haushalte tragen viel zur
bekämpfung dieser panne bei
auch hier muss sozusagen die wirtschaft
da muss rom auf es möglich macht auch
wirklich das zu greifen und natürlich
waren die erwartungen an den gestrigen
tag weniger was wird beibehalten sondern
was wird verändert und wir waren uns
alle einig dass die priorität
kinderbetreuung und grundschulen haben
denn die folgewirkung von wochenlangen
schließung der einrichtung sind
natürlich da und spürbar und die
anspannung der eltern ist groß
und trotzdem hätte ich mir an dieser
stelle gewünscht dass wir auch hier
entlang der instanz entscheiden aber ich
habe auch akzeptiert dass es eine
eigenständige kultur hat der länder gibt
vielleicht das innerste prinzip der
länder
und deshalb haben werden die länder sehr
verantwortlich in eigener hoheit
entscheiden wie sie das genau machen es
wird werden einige schulen vielleicht
schon nächste woche öffnen die
allermeisten am 22 aber immer nur die
grundschulen und die
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen die
grundschulen im wechsel unterricht mit
vielen hygienemaßnahmen das will ich
hier ausdrücklich sagen
damit haben wir haben dann über einen
weiteren öffnungs schritt gesprochen am
ersten märz werden die besucher öffnen
wir haben am ersten für den ersten märz
die gute aussicht dass wir
wir haben für den ersten märz die gute
aussicht dass wir eine instanz von 50
bundesweit erreichen können
wir haben heute eine instanz von 64,2
nach den aussagen des robert koch
instituts und wir haben dann über die
weiteren öffnungszeiten gesprochen
das ist natürlich das was jetzt von
größerem interesse ist und ich will hier
ausdrücklich sagen dass sich sehr
unterstütze dass wir uns bei diesen
weiteren öffnungs schritten auch im
blick auf die unsicherheiten der neuen
mutationen entschieden haben nicht datum
zu nennen sondern infektionszahlen also
instanzen zu nehmen und da sagt man sich
einander gut das gibt mir doch keine
planungssicherheit
aber wir gehen sozusagen mit dem virus
in einen kampf das ist unser gegner und
das virus richtet sich nicht nach daten
sondern das virus richtet sich nach
infektionszahlen und nachfragen die sich
die infektion ausbreitet deshalb haben
wir die nächsten weiteren öffnungs
schritt für eine inzidenz von 35 ins
auge gefasst manche sagen bekommt denn
diese instanzen wieder her
sie wissen 50 haben wir als einen punkt
im paragrafen 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes festgelegt ab
dem sehr sehr weitreichende maßnahmen
beschlossen werden kann und bei 35 wenn
man jetzt mal von unten kommt bereits
weitreichende massen dh der punkt 35er
incidents ist der punkt an dem ich am
ersten öffnungstag gehen kann und hier
haben wir gemeinsam beschlossen dass das
den einzelhandel galerien museen und
körpernahe dienstleistungen umfassen
soll
ich glaube das ist ein richtiger und
wichtiger ausblick und dann kommt es wie
geht es weiter mit den nächsten öffnungs
schritten
da muss ich ihnen folgendes sagen ja
bund und länder werden darüber beraten
und wir haben auch die verschiedenen
bereiche natürlich
genannt da geht es dann immer um die
frage kontakt beschränkungen im privaten
raum
da wird es auch um die frage der schulen
in den höheren klassen gehen
da wird es um die frage geben sport in
gruppen um freizeitgestaltung dann
gastronomie und hotels das wird ein
stufenweiser prozess seien von dem heute
noch nicht genau sagt es jedenfalls aus
meiner sicht bei welcher incident wir
was machen können weil wir jetzt erstmal
schauen müssen wie weit her
die kontakt nachverfolgung auch wirklich
schaffen wie weit wir mit der korona war
nicht mit der aufstockung der
gesundheitsämter mit besseren test
strategien all das liegt ja heute vor
wie weit wir auch mit unseren besseren
schutz maßnahmen dann immer weitere
lockerungen zu lassen können ohne wieder
ins exponentielle wachstum zu verfallen
und die villen sagen mein ziel ist dass
wir eben die neue welle die kommen
könnte wenn das neue virus oberhand
gewinnt das wir dir keinen raum geben
und nicht wieder einen solchen
exponentiellen anstieg von 2 zahlen
haben sondern dass wir alles tun um die
kontrolle der kontakt nach verfolgung zu
behalten und damit keine große dritte
welle auslöste
das bedeutet aber auch dass wir achtsam
sein müssen
ich glaube nicht dass das hin und her
einmal öffnen einmal wieder schließen
für die menschen mehr berechenbarkeit
bringt als ein paar tage länger zu
warten und sich den überblick darüber zu
verschaffen dass man ein kontinuierlich
prozess wirklich auch und das genau und
das genau ist doch die das genau ist
doch die spannung auch unter der wir
alle leben und die spüre ich genauso
visiert davon können sie ausgehen wer
möchte nicht gute nachrichten verkünden
jeder weiß ich habe es am anfang gesagt
wie der die menschen leiden und trotzdem
glaube ich war es gestern richtig sich
auf die schule
die friseure und dann den ersten
öffnungsstunden bestimmten incidents zu
konzentrieren und so werden wir auch
weitermachen
meine damen und herren das was den
gestern vereinbart haben davon bin ich
überzeugt ist geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig es gibt insbesondere
auch weiterhin kein milderes mittel als
konsequente kontakt beschränken allen
genannten bereichen um das
infektionsgeschehen nachhaltig und
behält auf einem beherrschbaren niveau
zu bringen und doch dort zu halten und
ich glaube am gestrigen tag gab es noch
eine wichtige botschaft die alle braucht
mit interesse und freude zur kenntnis
genommen haben denn die sehnlichst
erwarteten anträge für die
überbrückungshilfe drei können seit
gestern gestellt werden
es wird abschlag sagen schauen sie ich
weiß wie viele menschen auf das geld
warten ich weiß welche not ist und wie
viele menschen keine liquidität mehr
haben ich weiß wie der einzelhandel
leidet und an raucht aber eines will ich
an dieser stelle dann auch sagen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
bundesfinanzminister haben versprochen
dass im februar die anträge gestellt
werden können und dass diese anträge
werden dass abschlagszahlungen
beantwortet werden dass ab märz die aus
durch die länder erfolgen wir haben
heute den 11 februar gestern war der
zehnte februar
das war es versprochen wurde ist
eingehalten und trotzdem ist es für die
betroffene ende wahnsinnig lange zeit
gewesen und ich bin froh dass das jetzt
so ist wie es ist aber es war ein
wichtiger und sehnlichst erwartet doch
steht präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
dieser winter ist hart da draußen
genauso wie in dem was er mit unserem
leben macht aber wir haben unser ziel
klar vor augen immer klarer
wir sind die mehr sehr weit von
infektionszahlen entfernt die uns
schritt und schritt um schritt wieder
öffnungen und freiheiten ermöglichen
können weil eben infektionsketten wieder
nachverfolgt werden können und weil die
überlassung des gesundheitssystems
verhindert wird all die anstrengungen
und entbehrungen jetzt noch einmal bis
zum 7 märz fortzusetzen um die mutation
klein zu halten und hoffentlich deutlich
unter die 7 tage instituts von 50 zu
kommen das ist aus meiner sicht die
anstrengung wird es geht immer wieder
darum dass wir weiter deutlich sinkenden
zahlen haben wir müssen ausdauernd sein
und wir müssen geduldig sein und ich
weiß dass an einem solchen tag wie heute
keine leichte bitte ist aber die
menschen können auf einen start setzten
auf eine bundesregierung die alles was
sinnvoll und möglich ist in bewegung
setzt um denen zu helfen die hilfe
brauchen damit sie über diese so schwere
zeit kommen am ende das ist meine feste
überzeugung und das ist auch mein
auftrag den ich bis zum letzten tag
meiner amtszeit erfüllen werde
am ende können wir es gemeinsam schaffen
diese pandemie zu besiegen und unser
land wieder in bessere zeiten zu führen
herzlichen dank
jetzt endlich die aussprache mit der
teil des lotte fraktionsvorsitzende der
af ddr alles weiter
sehr geehrter herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin sehr geehrte damen und
herren das unwürdige schauspiel geht in
die nächste runde
eine von der verfassung nicht
vorgesehene kugelrunde beschließt im
hinterzimmer weitreichende eingriffe in
das leben und in die freiheit der bürger
die kanzlerin legt vorher fest was dabei
herauskommen soll
die ministerpräsidenten betreiben im
vorfeld pr in eigener sache spielen
opposition letztlich fügen sie sich doch
das parlament jedoch die stimme des
souveräns darf hinterher noch ein wenig
darüber debattieren wie heute ist aber
in die entscheidung nicht eingebunden
was für eine peinliche inszenierung was
für eine dreiste zurschaustellung von
arroganz der macht sehr geehrte damen
und herren
und was für eine offene missachtung der
bürger die unter ihren einsamen
beschlüssen leiden wo mit denen sie
umspringen wie mit untertanen über deren
leben rechte schicksale sie nach
belieben verfügen zu können glauben was
die bundesregierung hier betreibt ist
verfassungswidrig
sie spielen mit der zukunft unserer
kinder
es ist nicht das virus oder die pandemie
die einer ganzen generation von schülern
und kindern die bildungschancen raubt es
ist ihre falsche politik die nur verbot
und zwar zu kennen scheint die jungen
und älteren menschen familien und
berufstätigen selbstständigen und
unternehmern wertvolle lebenszeit nimmt
sie in depression einsamkeit und in den
ruin treibt
drei monate wellenbrecher lockdown und
sie wollen noch mal einen monat
dranhängen die kollateralschäden ihrer
methode von einsperren und dicht machen
wachsen ins unermessliche
die deutsche herzstiftung befürchtet
einen massiven anstieg von hertz toten
weil eingeschüchterte patienten nicht
zum arzt gehen ausgebliebene
vorsorgeuntersuchungen werden auch die
zahl der krebstoten ansteigen
auch auf dem arbeitsmarkt hinterlässt
diese lockdown politik eine spur der
verwüstung
eine halbe million neue arbeitslose
millionen kurzarbeiter 175000
unternehmer und selbstständige die vor
der insolvenz stehen gastronome und
gewerbetreibende ihre lebenswerk
zerbricht
einzelhändler die ihre letzten reserven
längst verbraucht haben die auf werden
von unverkaufte ware und schulden sitzen
aber von den großspurig angekündigten
hilfen noch immer nichts gesehen haben
das haben sie eben zugegeben ich frage
mich wollen sie den mittelstand das
rückgrat unseres wohlstands vernichten
wollen sie uns auf den stand eines
entwicklungslandes bringen dann sagen
sie es bitte ganz offen die leute wollen
das wissen woran sie sind wenn sie das
nächste mal zur wahl gehen sehr geehrte
damen und herren und sie klammern sich
an den wirtschafts und
verfassungsfeindlichen lockdown als gäbe
es keine intelligenteren alternativen
und stadt den bürgern eine verlässliche
perspektive für die rückkehr zur
normalität zu bieten
verändern sie laufen willkürlich die
parameter verdopplung seit er wird
sieben tage incidents die für die 200er
ins ident beschlossenen maßnahmen
einfach bis zu einem incidents wert von
35 fortzuführen ist ein erneuter
rechtsbruch das muss man ja ganz klar
sagen die schnell impfung
großer teile der bevölkerung die sie
ebenfalls zur zielgröße erklärt haben
hat ihre regierung grandios versiebt
weil sie die zuständigkeit unterbrechung
das subsidiaritätsprinzip nach brüssel
delegiert haben und jetzt sind es neu
aufgetretene virus varianten
sie sagen mutanten das klingt bedrohlich
diaz lockdown rechtfertigung herhalten
müssen die bürger haben dieses hin und
her ich muss es ihnen ganz klar sagen
diese hinhaltepolitik satt sie wollen
nicht länger für politikversagen in
geiselhaft genommen werden
sie fühlen sich mit recht für dumm
verkauft wenn sie erfahren dass die
innenminister schon vor dem ersten
lockdown bei willfährigen
wissenschaftler möglichst dramatische
szenarien angefordert hat um harte
einschränkungen einfordern zu können
oder wenn er rauskommt dass das
kanzleramt mit hastig hingeworfenen
bestellten gefälligkeitsgutachten auch
schnelle und lang schulschließung
hingewirkt hat wo sie ihre günstlinge
hinsetzen um es mal ganz klar zu sagen
da versagen diese herr altmaier bei der
entschädigung der von zwang schließung
betroffenen gewerbetreibenden und frau
von der leyen bei der organisation der
impfstoff beschaffung dass ich schon
atemberaubend sich hinzustellen und zu
behaupten es sei im großen und ganzen
nichts schief gelaufen und die
bundesregierung tue ihr bestes
ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen was
alles passiert sein muss dass sie
endlich mal fehler eingestehen unfassbar
die korona politik in unserem land muss
grundlegend neu ausgerichtet werden
wir brauchen den raschen und
verbindlichen ausstieg aus dem lot da
der weg dorthin muss öffentlich und
unter einbeziehung des parlaments
beraten werden
dafür muss ohne diffamierung und
ausgrenzung die gesamte bandbreite der
fachlichen und wissenschaftlichen
expertise gehört werden
ziel muss sein die hochbetagten
und vor erkranken in öffentlichen
einrichtungen besonders zu schützen
allen anderen gefährdeten
selbstverantwortlichen eigenschutz zu
ermöglichen
genügend impfstoff für alle impfwilligen
bereitzustellen das gesundheitssystem so
zu stärken dass es mit den
unvermeidlichen erkrankung fertig wird
und allen bürgern ein möglichst normales
leben zu ermöglichen dafür zahlen sie
nämlich steuern und dafür zahlen sie
auch in das sozialversicherungssystem an
die grundrechte müssen wieder in kraft
gesetzt werden
sie werden von der verfassung garantiert
und nicht von der regierung zugeteilt
eine einschränkung ist
begründungspflicht ich und nicht ihre
wiederherstellung sehr geehrte damen und
herren
und das ist natürlich nicht so leicht
wie drohen verbieten und geld verteilen
im dauer ausnahmezustand aber genau
dafür sind sie gewählt worden
kehren sie also zurück zu einer
verfassungsgemäßen politik gehen
nächster redner ist der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd rolf
mützenich
sehr geehrte präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die letzten wochen waren
für alle extrem anstrengend viele sind
an ihre grenzen gekommen kinder und
jugendliche eltern ältere menschen
pflege und medizin kräfte beschäftigte
in industrie und handel solo
selbstständige und ordnungskräfte alle
haben ihr bestes gegeben
selbst wenn wir in wenigen monaten die
pandemie eingegrenzt haben sollten die
nachwirkungen werden bleiben egal ob wir
erkrankt waren oder nicht
einige von uns haben angehörige verloren
oder freunde
andere wissen von häuslicher gewalt oder
haben sie selbst erlebt wieder andere
banken um bildungsabschlüsse oder ihren
arbeitsplatz
viel wird die rückkehr zur scheinbaren
normalität schwer fallen meine damen und
herren vor diesem hintergrund sind die
gestern beschlossenen maßnahmen eine
weitere last ja man hat nach all den
anstrengungen auf anderes gehofft
gleichwohl sind die beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz angemessen
notwendig und gut begründet sie
erfordern nochmals große strapazen und
disziplin das wissen wir die erfolge
sind sichtbar aber zerbrechlich durch
neue mutationen wächst die gefahr eines
noch strengeren lockt downs aber meine
damen und herren selbst wenn bei dieser
gratwanderung eine perspektive
erforderlich ist und sie ist es dann
geht es darum die frage zu stellen wann
lockerungen möglich sind und diese
fragen sind unerlässlich die rückkehr zu
einem weniger besteht
alltag muss anhand dynamischer und
nachvollziehbarer kriterien nach und
nach entstehen durch anpassungsfähigkeit
und transparenz können wir neue
freiräume schaffen
angesichts der sozialen bedeutung müssen
davon zuerst kinder und jugendliche
profitieren gleichzeitig meine damen und
herren werde ich aber auch die länder
die kinder und jugendhilfe nicht zu
vergessen auch hier brauchen junge
menschen zuwendung und die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter leisten
in der pandemie außerordentliches auch
ihnen gilt unser großer dank und meine
damen und herren
im rückblick wird erneut offensichtlich
wie verantwortungslos diejenigen waren
die die vorhersehbaren folgen
kleingeredet gar mit der zahl von
verkehrstoten verglichen haben
das war an zynismus nicht zu überbieten
sie haben dazu beigetragen dass manche
gefahren erkannt wurden
sie haben sich schuldig gemacht und wenn
jemand gegen die verfassung in diesem
haus verstößt dann sind sie es meine
damen und herren dabei verkennen wir
nichts dass entscheidungsprozesse und
abwägungen öffentlich stattfinden müssen
ein streitbarer pluraler und faire
austausch von argumenten es
unverzichtbar um einsichten zu schaffen
gerade wir parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier müssen dafür sorgen dass
einordnungen stattfinden absolute
wahrheiten gibt es auch in dieser
existenziellen krise nicht deswegen
meine damen und herren so lange wir die
pandemie nicht erfolgreich eingegrenzt
haben muss der staat immer wieder die
individuelle und gesellschaftliche
sicherheit herstellen und gleichheit
gleichzeitig freiheiten schützen
fundamental bleibt dabei soziale
stabilität und wirtschaftliche
zuversicht zu schaffen
wir sind überzeugt nur ein starker und
sozialer staat kann diese
herausforderungen bewältigen das ist
eine der wichtigsten erkenntnisse der
letzten monate und ist
die grundüberzeugung meiner partei von
anfang an meine damen und herren
dabei war es richtig mit aller kraft und
finanziellen engagement einzugreifen
heute können wir feststellen dass die
deutsche wirtschaft angesichts großer
hilfen besser durch die krise kommt als
andere volkswirtschaften aber auch
deswegen erwarten wir dass weitere
wirtschafts hilfen jetzt endlich
ankommen wir haben genügend geld dafür
bereitgestellt meine damen und herren
die finanziellen hilfen sind wichtig
aber ohne politik für arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer sowie für familien ist
alles andere vergeblich und deswegen hat
meine fraktion von anfang an dafür
gestritten dass das kurzarbeitergeld
nicht nur gewährt wird sondern dass
damit auch perspektiven verbunden sind
und ich kann mir erinnern manche
diskussion im koalitionsausschuss war
eben gerade nicht leicht gewesen frau
bundeskanzlerin und ich bin auch froh
dass wir sozialdemokraten uns bei der
letzten entscheidung dafür eingesetzt
haben dass ein kinder kranken tagebuch
gewährt werden kann eben für die eltern
wo die betreuungsangebote nicht
verlässlich da sind und das war wichtig
in dieser krise weil auch das schiff
perspektiven meine damen und herren und
gleichzeitig will ich daran erinnern
dass in der vergangenen woche und wir
bringen es in dieser woche auf den weg
ein zusätzliches kindergeld gewährt wird
das ist angemessen für die steigenden
ausgaben aber ich glaube auch wenn es
eben in den monaten auch gewährt wird zu
möglich auch für den konjunkturimpuls
wirkt aber auch dass leistungsbezieher
in der grundsicherung jetzt einen
einmaligen beitrag bekommen ist wichtig
gleichzeitig hätten wir uns gewünscht
nicht nur den erleichterten zugang bis
zum 31.12 dieses jahres zu gewähren
sondern eine grundsätzliche bereitschaft
gerade auch aus der pandemie zu lernen
nicht nur vor dem hintergrund der
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts sondern ich
sage auch ganz klar aus der
grundüberzeugung meiner partei
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen impfungen
bleiben der entscheidende hebel zur
besserung wir können stolz sein
früher brauchte man jahre meinen
sicheren impfstoff herzustellen
wir haben es wesentlich schneller
geschafft große erfindergeist war
notwendig und die einsicht wächst dass
vieles möglich ist wenn menschen ihre
potenziale gemeinsam mobilisieren und
nicht an ländergrenzen haltmachen
offenheit pluralität und bildung sind
die besten antworten für die lösung
komplexer probleme
auch das zeigt meine damen und herren
diese pandemie
mittlerweile wissen die meisten dass die
fragen die wir vor einigen wochen zur im
situation gestellt haben berechtigt
waren
zumal ist uns immer um fortschritte ging
heute haben wir eine überzeugendere
perspektive und alle konzentrieren sich
endlich auf noch bessere bedingungen und
sicherheiten uns dass wir die
impfstoffherstellung weiter steigern
können ist ein hoffnungsvolles zeichen
der deutsche bundestag wird hierbei
wieder ein entscheidendes wort mitreden
auch durch ein neu zu schaffendes
gremium welches unseren sachverstand
bündelt und die arbeit der
fachausschüsse stärkt meine damen und
herren ich bin überzeugt dass wir trotz
aller probleme zuversichtlich in das
noch junge jahr starten können
in wenigen wochen wissen wir ob die
impfte das virus noch übertragen dann
können wir freiheitsrechte nach und nach
zurück gewinnen
wer heute mehr verspricht handelt
fahrlässig was die mehrheit der menschen
gemeinsam mit uns schaffen ist jedoch
mehr als nur die bekämpfung der pandemie
es ging von anfang an liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen auch um die verteidigung
unseres demokratischen gemeinwesens wie
verletzlich demokratien sind zumal auch
ältere zeigt der blick in andere
regionen dieser welt
in den usa hat ein ehemaliger präsident
ein staatsstreich angezettelt es waren
verwirrende bilder bei der
amtseinführung das mit militär ein
parlament geschützt werden musste
und immer noch ist es war
ein leichtfertig herbeigeführter dragset
lässt nur verlierer zurück und wenn ich
nach italien schaue bin ich zwar froh
heute dass man hoffen kann dass ein ende
der regierungskrise absehbar ist aber
dass fahrlässig in demokratien so
gehandelt wird ist eine große last die
auf uns liegt deswegen meine damen und
herren demokratien sind empfindsam als
andere politische ordnungen
das macht sie angreifbarer gleichwohl
ist die anziehungskraft demokratische
ideale ungebrochen schauen wir nach
minsk budapest hongkong moskau hongkong
und kampala um die kraft der sozialen
demokratie zu stärken haben wir uns der
pandemie ebenso entgegengestemmt mit
ganzer verantwortung und konzentration
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
jetzt verteidigt das wort der
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp christian
lindner herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen diese regierungserklärung
war dringlich
denn selten zuvor war die politik der
regierung so erklärungsbedürftig
wesentliche inhalte kannten wir aber
bereits nicht erst seit der
pressekonferenz vom gestrigen abend bei
der unterrichtung der
fraktionsvorsitzenden denn vorgestern
bereits haben medien berichtet über das
was das bundeskanzleramt mit den
landesregierungen besprechen will
während gestern das parlament hier
getagt hat und sich mit anderen dingen
beschäftigt hat war für die breite
öffentlichkeit die
entscheidungsgrundlage der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bereits im
internet zum download verfügbar
ich rate ab frau merkel diesen umgang
mit dem parlament zur ständigen
staatspraxis werden zu lassen
aus gutem grund haben drei fraktionen
dieses hauses deshalb dazu geraten und
dringend darum gebeten dass sie vor der
runde mit den ländern den deutschen
bundestag über ihre absichten und
grundlinien unterrichten
damit haben wir nichts unmögliches
verlangt denn im vorfeld des
europäischen rates entspricht das der
praxis der regierung und entspricht dem
umgang der regierung mit diesem
parlament
das hätte die möglichkeit geboten das
sie ihre maßnahmenvorschläge darstellen
es hätte die chance eröffnet auch die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen zu
hinterfragen und es wäre vor allen
dingen darum gegangen alternative
strategien hier in die debatte
einzubringen
sie haben diese möglichkeit leider
ausgeschlagen dabei wäre es eine chance
auch für ihre regierung gewesen um
verständnis und vertrauen der menschen
zu werben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
es unverändert mit einer gefährlichen
pandemie zu tun
wer die gefahren die mit der corvette
erkrankung verbunden sind relativiert
der handelt fahrlässig oder gar
vorsätzlich aber wir leben nun auch ein
jahr in und mit dieser pandemie
wir haben wie die frau bundeskanzlerin
gesagt hat gelernt die infektionszahlen
gehen zurück
es gibt zu langsame und zu beschwerlich
aber immerhin fortschritte bei den
impfungen und deshalb und angesichts der
grossen erschöpfung in unserer
gesellschaft waren die erwartungen an
die gestrige runde groß diese hoffnungen
sind enttäuscht worden denn viele
menschen haben sich mehr erwartet als
einen frischen haarschnitt
der wesentlicher ansatz ihrer strategie
findet sich auch in dieser vorlage ich
zitiere der grundsatz wir bleiben zu
hause bleibt das wesentliche instrument
im kampf gegen die pandemie zitat ende
wirklich auch nach einem jahr noch trotz
allem was wir gelernt haben hangeln wir
uns seit oktober november von einem lock
down von einem gipfel zum nächsten ohne
eine klare perspektive
das ist bestenfalls einfallslos mit
sicherheit frau merkel ist das nicht
alternativlos
christiane woopen die vorsitzende des
europäischen ethikrates in diesem haus
von vielen sehr geschätzt und mit
sicherheit eine verantwortungsbewusste
und umsichtige persönlichkeit hat dieser
tage in einem interview folgendes gesagt
ich zitiere seit einem jahr drehen sich
diese runden fast unverändert um das
gleiche den lock down
ich halte es für dringend erforderlich
eine perspektive zu eröffnen statt
durchhalteparolen zu verkünden und
weiter vor open
ich habe kein verständnis mehr dafür
dass man vorhandene technologien nicht
nutzt
wir haben dafür auch kein verständnis
mehr verraten orientieren wir uns nicht
antun wie tübingen oder rostock wo sind
die wirksam und hier im hause oft genug
angemahnten strategien zum wirklichen
schutz der hohen erwartungen gruppen und
zwar nicht nur ein alten und pflegeheim
sondern auch etwa durch die oft hier
angemahnten exklusiven zeitfenster für
den einkauf oder taxi gutscheine
wo ist die bereit sich initiative
luftfilter in die praxis zu bringen wo
setzen wir systematisch schnelltests ein
und warum wurde die korona war nett mit
großen erwartungen öffentlich
vorgestellt
und dann nach technologisch kein
bisschen weiterentwickelt
deshalb bleiben wir hinter unseren
möglichkeiten zurück und deshalb
orientieren wir uns ausschließlich auf
den stillstand statt auch mit der
bedrohung durch das virus neue
möglichkeiten für gesellschaftliches
leben zu eröffnen und die werden wir
brauchen denn wir können uns nicht
sicher sein dass dies die einzige
zoonose ist mit der die menschheit in
den nächsten jahren umzugehen hat wir
können uns noch nicht mal sicher sein ob
es nicht der einzelne mutation geben
könnte dieser erkrankung auf die die
impfung eben nicht mehr die wirksame
antwort ist mindestens nicht mit den
vorhandenen impfstoffen
also brauchen wir jetzt methoden und
eine infrastruktur mit der wir die
pandemie besser ausbalancieren mit dem
gesundheitsschutz der notwendig ist aber
der freiheit die die menschen auch leben
müssen
über monate haben wir uns an der zahl 50
nach den instanzen orientiert obwohl sie
eine politische setzung ist obwohl
oberbürgermeister auch
cdu-oberbürgermeister sagen
selbstverständlich können sie auch mehr
als 50 infektionen pro 100000 einwohner
in der woche inzwischen nachverfolgen
wir haben uns auf diese zahl von 50 in
deutschland fixiert und nun wird sie
ersetzt durch die 35 in der zentralen
bedeutung und wir wissen dass im
kanzleramt auch schon über die 10 als
zahl gesprochen worden ist
dadurch dass die wesentliche
entscheidungsgrundlage ausgetauscht wird
ohne vorbereitung ohne klare
argumentation gefährden sie die
akzeptanz der maßnahmen in der
bevölkerung insgesamt
wo ist die berechenbarkeit
im infektionsschutzgesetz übrigens wird
ausdrücklich auch ein regionaler zugang
angemahnt im von der großen koalition
beschlossenen infektionsschutzgesetz
wird angemahnt regional zu
differenzieren
tatsächlich haben wir heute bereits eine
vielzahl von landkreisen unter 50
darunter 35 und trotzdem gelten dort die
gleichen beschränkungen wie in den hot
hot spots mit über 200 ha incidents da
ist bereits der zweifel an der
verhältnismäßigkeit angelegt frau
bundeskanzlerin
es ist richtig kitas und schulen zu
öffnen aber auch in ihrer
regierungserklärung hier haben sie
gerade deutlich gemacht mit recht
hinhaltenden widerstand aus dem
kanzleramt
dies erfolgt herr kretschmann hat das in
der runde dem vernehmen nach gestern
auch angesprochen warum stellt frau kali
check finanziert mit öffentlichen
fördergeldern in dieser woche eine
wissenschaftliche studie vor
unter welchen bedingungen mit welchem
paket an maßnahmen in der pandemie die
förderung von kindern und jugendlichen
in kitas und schulen möglich ist wenn
die eigenen empfehlungen des
bundesbildungsministeriums im
bundeskanzleramt nicht ernst genommen
werden sie öffnen die friseure
sie öffnen die friseure obwohl das eine
so genannte körpernahe dienstleistung
ist man sich wirklich nun sehr nahe
kommt beim haarschnitt das ermöglichen
sie war sie weil sie sagen gut da gibt
es für gene konzepte da wird die maske
getragen und deshalb ist es
verantwortbar den friseur zu öffnen das
ist richtig aber gibt es solche hygiene
konzepte nur bei den friseuren nicht in
gleicher weise im sport in
fitnessstudios die auch gesundheits
präventive wirkung haben gibt es diese
gesundheitskonzepte nicht auch im
bereich der kosmetik sind sie
ausgeschlossen beim handel gar in der
gastronomie sind solche gene konzepte
denkbar
deshalb trägt die entscheidung für die
friseure
bereits den makel einer nicht
systematischen ausnahme was wir brauchen
ist eine systematik klarer wenn dann
regeln weil nur dass die berechenbarkeit
für die menschen und übrigens auch für
die behörden bringt diese systematik im
wege eines stufenplans war von ihnen vor
drei wochen ja bereits auch angekündigt
worden
diese arbeitsgruppe falls sie getagt
hatte kein ergebnis
wir haben deshalb in dieser woche einen
7 stufenplan vorgelegt mit welcher
systematik es möglich ist regional zu
öffnen
und dieser von uns vorgelegten
stufenplan ist natürlich getragen von
unseren grundüberzeugungen vielleicht
stärker als andere fraktionen hier im
haus setzen ihr vertrauen in die
eigenverantwortung der menschen und
setzen wir darauf dass es für große
probleme auch innovative technische
lösungen gibt das muss nicht jeder
teilen
aber es gibt eben auch andere stufen
pläne innerhalb der landesregierung von
rheinland pfalz mit sozialdemokratie und
den grünen wird darüber nachgedacht die
landesregierung von schleswig-holstein
mit union und grünen und fdp war die
erste die einen solchen stufenplan
vorgelegt hat wem also unser stufenplan
der hier liberalen charakter hat zu weit
gehend ist der findet mit unterstützung
der eigenen kolleginnen und kollegen in
den ländern auch politische alternativen
dass sie als bundesregierung dennoch und
tätig geworden sind und den einmal nicht
erfüllten arbeitsauftrag einfach in die
zukunft fortschreiben das zeigt dass sie
in wahrheit gar kein interesse an einem
solchen perspektiv plan haben so
notwendig er auch ist deshalb verehrte
anwesende meine damen und herren ist
diese regierungserklärung eine
enttäuschung sie ist bedauerlicherweise
nur ein weiter so und mein letzter
gedanke wenn sie schon den locker und
jetzt weiter verschärfen wer weiß wie
lange dann passen sie ihre
wirtschaftlichen hilfen auch an ein
schweres versäumnis
dass die sozialdemokratie und herr
scholz immer noch nicht ihren widerstand
aufgegeben haben gegen das
unbürokratisch schnellste und wirksamste
instrument betriebe und selbständige zu
unterstützen nämlich den vollen
steuerlichen verlust rück tag und zwar
auf die ganzen letzten jahre seit 2000
jetzt hat das wort der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu/csu als
brinkhaus herr präsident meine damen und
herren
herr lindner die zahl 50 und auch die
zahl 35 die stehenden § 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz hier im deutschen
bundestag beschlossen und sind insofern
nicht willkürlich und dass sie ihre
behauptung der deutsche bundestag wäre
ja nicht beteiligt meine damen und
herren
wenn wir uns die entwicklung der letzten
wochen und monate angucken da muss man
sagen der locker und wirkt wir kommen
voran instanzen vor neue
infektionszahlen von knapp 200 wir sind
jetzt unter 65 das heißt die maßnahmen
haben gewirkt und wir liegen übrigens
auch im europäischen vergleich mit
unseren neuinfektionen sehr sehr gut
besser als viele viele andere länder
besser als viele nachbarländer wir
liegen auch insgesamt noch sehr gut bei
der anzahl der infizierten auf 100000
einwohner und auch ja bei der anzahl der
toten auf 100000 einwohner was schlecht
ist das gehört zur wahrheit leider auch
dazu ist die anzahl der toten bei den
hochbetagten das ist eine sache wo wir
uns als gesellschaft fragen müssen ob
wir dort alles richtig gemacht haben die
wir kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen
und herren das war jetzt sehr
interessant jetzt sagt herr lindner da
muss die cdu sich fragen
also ich finde schon sehr sehr
interessant wie sie mit dieser krise
umgehen wie sie versuchen
parteipolitisches kapital zu schlagen
wie sie versuchen wahlkampf zu machen in
der schwersten krise die diese republik
hat es ist erbärmlich erlitten und die
wählerinnen und wähler zeigen es ihnen
auch bei den umfragen dass das nicht
verfängt was sie hier veranstalten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind beim thema impfen auch zu
langsam aber mittlerweile ins rollen
gekommen und wir sind auch beim thema
wirtschafts hilfen und das muss man an
dieser stelle auch sagen viel viel
umfangreicher unterwegs als die meisten
anderen länder und ja herr mütze nicht
da gehört auch das kurzarbeitergeld dazu
dazu gehörten vereinfachter zugang bei
hartz4 dazu es ist ein gesamtpaket was
wir im bereich wirtschaft auf den weg
gebracht haben und es ist gut dass die
überbrückungshilfe drei jetzt auch
ausgezahlt wird liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und für all diejenigen die
jetzt sagen ja aber einen anderen
ländern ist es besser ja andere länder
haben andere umstände australien ist
eine insel und wir können uns gerne mal
die repressionsmaßnahmen in china
angucken ob wir die hier haben wollen
und im übrigen ist es so dass andere
länder auch nicht so viele hochbetagte
haben wie wir
aber eins ist auch richtig alle länder
die besser durch die pandemie gekommen
sind als wir haben zuerst einen
radikalen lockdown gehabt und haben
zuerst die zahlen nach unten geknüppelt
nach unten geprügelt und deswegen ist es
auch richtig was wir hier machen dass
wir sagen bevor wir in differenzierte
maßnahmen einsteigen müssen wir erst die
zahlen nach unten kriegen und das ist
genau die politik die jetzt auch gestern
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
entsprechend weitergeführt wird und
diese politik die ist richtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen ist es auch voll zu
unterstützen dass die knock down
maßnahmen weitergeführt werden sorgen
bereitet mir allerdings auch wenn es in
unserem grundgesetz vorgesehen ist dass
die länder individuell darüber
entscheiden die schulen und die kitas
wieder zu öffnen
ich habe da meine zweifel ob das in
dieser phase richtig ist weil wenn wir
malt uns betrachten wo wir herkommen und
die bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt wir
kommen von instanzen unter 10 unter 5
und da müssen wir auch wieder hin um
entsprechend die öffnung hin zu kriegen
natürlich ist es sehr sehr hart für die
schülerinnen und schüler für die eltern
für die familien und das erkennen wir
auch an dass es hat es essen ist eine
zumutung aber es ist auch eine zumutung
dass mehr als 60.000 menschen in diesem
land gestorben sind liebe kollegin
oder auch das muss man immer wieder im
hinterkopf behalten wenn man über
freiheitsrechte redet und nicht bleibe
dabei herr lindner was sich hier vor
einigen wochen gesagt habe freiheit ist
auch immer die freiheit der schwachen
und nicht nur die freiheit der starken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber wenn wir einmal nach vorne schauen
dann reicht das ja jetzt nicht dass
ministerpräsidenten dass das
bundeskabinett das wir hier uns klar
darüber sind wie es entsprechend weiter
geht sondern es gibt eine menge die noch
dinge die noch zu tun sind
ich möchte in fünf gängen denn wo wir
jetzt ran müssen das erste ist das thema
schulen ja es ist die länderkompetenz
aber trotzdem erwarte ich gerade vor dem
hintergrund dass jetzt wieder öffnungen
auf den weg gebracht werden test
strategien lüftung strategien logistik
strategien dass die schulbusse nicht
mehr sofort sind beim thema schulen
erwarte ich dass es eine
lernstandserhebung gibt was ist verpasst
worden dass es konzepte dafür gibt über
den sommer hinweg durch nachhilfe durch
sommerakademie wie dieser stoff
aufgeholt werden kann
das ist konzepte dafür gibt wie
insbesondere die kinder gefördert werden
die in benachteiligten familien
aufwachsen wo nicht geholfen werden kann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
gehört natürlich auch dazu ich glaube
wir haben im bereich schule sehr sehr
viel zu tun
der zweite bereich gesundheitsämter das
rückgrat unserer pandemie bekämpfung
sind die gesundheitsämter ja wir haben
einen pakt für das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen ja wir haben mehr geld
bereitgestellt aber dieses geld muss
jetzt auch entsprechend umgesetzt werden
die software frage muss schnell gelöst
werden wir müssen die prozesse
analysieren und wir brauchen eine
monitoringstelle wo die qualität der
gesundheitsämter auch tatsächlich
kontrolliert wird sonst können sie nicht
das rückgrat der bekämpfung der pandemie
sein und dazu gehört ja auch eine
adäquate bezahlung der mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in den gesundheitsämtern
dritter großer bereich altenheime wir
haben jetzt viele erfolge erzielt beim
impfen der hochbetagten menschen die in
den altenheimen wohnen wir brauchen aber
eine weiterführende strategie was ist
mit den menschen die jetzt neu
aufgenommen werden die noch nicht
geimpft sind wo gibt es da das konzept
das flächendeckend sichergestellt wird
dass derjenige der neuen einem altenheim
aufgenommen wird auch geimpft wird wie
führen wir die test strategien weiter
es reicht ja jetzt nicht zu sagen alle
sind geimpfte und alles ist gut und vor
allen dingen müssen wir eins machen und
das habe ich eben schon mal gesagt und
das ist das große problem was wir in
dieser pandemie gehabt haben warum sind
so viele menschen in den alten und
pflegeheimen gestorben was ist dort
falsch gemacht worden und zwar nicht um
hiermit auf den finger mit dem finger
auf irgendjemand zu zeigen sondern um
die dinge auch in die zukunft besser zu
lösen und vor allen dingen auch eine
höhere sicherheit für die menschen dort
zu erzielen
vierter bereich impfen ja wir schaffen
jetzt mehr impfstoff das ist gut wir
brauchen eine zweite sache wir brauchen
ein besseres impftermin vergabe
management was in einigen bundesländern
in den letzten wochen passiert ist das
80 jährige über 80-jährigen
telefonschleifen tagelang fest gehangen
haben dass sie in online schleifen
gesessen haben das ist nicht akzeptabel
und das ist würde und respektlos
gegenüber den alten menschen in diesem
land und wenn wir über das thema impfen
reden dann müssen wir uns auch darauf
vorbereiten dass diese pandemie nicht
vorbei ist dass wir vielleicht nachher
zu müssen dass wir noch mal impfen
müssen dass die nächste pandemie kommt
und deswegen brauchen wir eine
impfstrategie 20 22 und 1 haben wir
gelernt
bei aller wertschätzung für
globalisierte wertschöpfungsketten
wir brauchen eine im produktionsalltag
ii innerhalb der europäischen union
wenn wir nicht in der lage sind unseren
impfstoff selbst herzustellen
dann werden wir immer abhängig sein von
anderen regierungen von anderen regionen
und dafür ist die frage zu ernst und
beim thema impfen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte ich auch noch einem
punkt hinweisen
wir tun ja immer hier so als wenn das
hier alles so langsam ist und nicht
schnell genug geht und das mag
vielleicht auch richtig sein aber die
meisten länder in dieser welt ins noch
gar nicht insbesondere schwellenländer
insbesondere länder in der dritten welt
und ich glaube wir haben die
verpflichtung die moralische
verpflichtung dass wir auch impfstoff
weltweit zur verfügung stellen und wir
sollten nicht nur an uns denken sondern
wir sollten auch an die welt denken
wenn wir über das thema in frieden und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt
noch einen weiteren punkt und da können
wir nicht warten bis die pandemie vorbei
ist wobei ich sowieso die befürchtung
habe wenn die pandemie vorbei ist dann
werden wir uns wieder anderen dingen
zuwenden und nicht den katastrophen
nicht den dingen die auf uns zukommen
können denn diese pandemie wird nicht
die letzte katastrophe seien sie wird
nicht die letzte pandemie seien die
nächste katastrophe kann im cyber
bereich stattfinden können klimafolgen
sein wie dürre wie hochwasser und viele
andere sachen
und wir haben eigentlich die mechanismen
dass wir eine risikoanalyse machen ja
wir hatten auch eine risikoanalyse zu
pandemien aber wir haben sie nicht ernst
genug genommen und dementsprechend
müssen wir uns intensiver auch mit einer
katastrophenvorsorge beschäftigen wir
haben auch nicht die gesetzlichen
grundlagen ich bin der meinung dass der
deutsche bundestag sehr sehr gut und
vernünftig mit der sache umgegangen ist
dass wir gesetzliche grundlage in kurzer
zeit geschaffen haben aber wir müssen
uns grund ständig damit beschäftigen was
ist denn bei nationalen notstand
wir haben eine notstandsgesetzgebung im
wesentlichen für den verteidigungsfall
aber wir glauben doch alle nicht also
dass die gerichte große katastrophe in
diesem land der verteidigungsfall sein
wird sondern das wird was anderes sein
und ja wir müssen das verhältnis
exekutive und legislative aufklären und
definieren und zwar für alle
katastrophen und für alle nationalen und
europäischen notstände und wir müssen
mal lieben kolleginnen und kollegen 1
machen
wir müssen wir müssen uns besser darauf
vorbereiten wir haben super
katastrophenstäbe in den einzelnen
landkreisen und in den städten
wir sind super regional aufgestellt mit
den feuerwehren mit den
hilfsorganisationen aber die bund länder
koordination die operative bund länder
koordination bei katastrophen 24 stunden
7 tage in der woche ständige
katastrophenstäbe stimme die auch üben
meine damen und herren die bundeswehr
hat 70 jahre geübt dass irgendwelche
panzer an unserer grenze stehen sie sind
gott sei dank nicht gekommen wir müssen
katastrophen üben wir müssen
automatismen schaffen dass wir mit
diesen katastrophen besser klarkommen
darum geht es jetzt und das muss die
lehre aus dieser pandemie seien
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
insofern haben wir sehr sehr
viel noch zu tun und wir sollten das
angehen wir müssen jetzt alles dafür tun
dass diese pandemie aufhört aber ehrlich
gesagt diese krise wäre eine vergeudete
krise wenn wir dich daraus lernen wir
müssen lernen und einige punkte habe ich
ihnen aufgezeigt vielen dank
nächster redner ist der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken dietmar
bartsch
herr präsident meine damen und herren
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer frau
bundeskanzlerin
es mag sie nerven aber ich will
ausdrücklich festhalten
für die linke bleibt es inakzeptabel
dass wir im bundestag erst wieder nach
einer ministerpräsidenten runde
debattieren und nicht vorher in der
krise in der krise zeigt sich die stärke
der demokratie und ihrer institutionen
und der bundestag gehört dazu
bundeskanzlerin sie sind der auffassung
dass im großen und ganzen ist nichts
schief gelaufen
er bringt ihm den satz gesagt sinngemäß
selbst bei den toten liegen wir gut den
würde ich nochmal überprüfen
ich will festhalten dass viele menschen
in unserem land das anders sehen mit dem
schief gelaufen
sie haben auch heute wieder 0 selbst
kritik geäußert aber vergleichsweise
viel selbstgefälligkeit auch eine
bundeskanzlerin steht ein gewisses maß
ein mindestmaß an selbstkritik gut zu
gesicht meine damen und herren
bundeskanzlerin sie haben auch
vorschläge aus diesem haus von uns von
den grünen von der fdp wenig gehört und
im sommer und im herbst das land nicht
auf den corona winter entsprechend
vorbereitet wenn nur ein beispiel nennen
im herbst ist hier über ein
schutzkonzept für heime gesprochen
worden auch viele experten haben das
eingefordert und täglich sterben weiter
viele menschen in alten- und pflegeheim
weil sie nicht geschützt werden und der
impfstoff in hessen zb haben im januar
73 prozent derjenigen die ancona
verstorben sind aus alten und
pflegeheime und sie sagen da ist nichts
schief gelaufen das sterben in den
heimen ist vielleicht das dunkelste
kapitel der letzten jahrzehnte
und dazu gab es übrigens nie einen
gipfel nicht dass wir als opposition das
alles besser gemacht hätten darum geht
es überhaupt nicht
aber diese papst attitüde der
unfehlbarkeit die ist in dieser
situation unangebracht meine damen
deshalb in einer historischen
ausnahmesituation oder das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger über das wir alle
sprechen das höchste gut ist sollten
fehler zugegeben werden und nicht
selbstgerecht vom tisch gewischt werden
und in den letzten monaten meine damen
und herren ist vieles schiefgelaufen vom
pandemie weltmeister im frühjahr sind
wir abgestiegen in den im keller europas
wir haben seit wochen seit wochen lehre
im cent würden millionen verzweifelte
bürger die stundenlang in warteschleifen
stecken und sie sagen es ist nicht
schief gelaufen beim impfen stehen wir
hinter rumänien hinter griechenland
hinter der slowakei bahnhöfen
wir sind selbst in der eu weit
abgeschlagen und frau bundeskanzlerin
deutschland hatte im vergangenen jahr
von juli bis dezember die
ratspräsidentschaft der eu
natürlich ist es richtig das europäisch
bestellt wurde das bestreitet doch von
uns ihnen niemand aber überaus fraglich
ist in der tat warum sie eine frühere
ministerin damit beauftragt haben die
schon einmal an verträgen gescheitert
ist wovon allein nach dem berater
skandal im verteidigungsministerium den
ausrichtenden europa zu ermöglichen war
augenscheinlich ein fehler aber zurück
in krisen möglich
deutschland in deutschland wachsen die
unzufriedenheit verzweiflung und auch
mut das hat sich auch nach gestern sich
geändert und das wissen sie und herr
brinkhaus hat die länder wo es nicht
funktioniert genannt aber in den usa in
großbritannien israel in vielen anderen
ländern wird in rekordtempo geimpft und
in deutschland erleben die menschen
aktuell irgendein impfte werke das ist
die wahrheit und sie müssen drei fragen
den bürgerinnen und bürgern beantworten
erstmals waren bestellte die eu unter
deutscher ratspräsidentschaft den
impfstoff in deutschland mit viel
steuergeldern gefördert gefördert hat
vier monate später als großbritannien
und die usa waren bestellte die veu
zweitens unter deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft weniger impfdosen
von biotech und moderne als möglich
waren und warum hat es deutschland
zugelassen dass beim preis gefeilscht
worden ist 520 millionen impfdosen
wurden zunächst weniger bestellt andere
staaten haben nicht geknausert als es um
das leben ihrer bürgerinnen und bürger
gehen und drittens warum hat sich die eu
unter deutscher ratspräsidentschaft und
die bundesregierung selbst im jahr 2020
nicht um die ausweitung der
produktionskapazitäten gekümmert der
impf gipfel vergangene woche
der war faktisch ein placebo sie haben
die impfstoffentwicklung zurecht
gefördert aber die produktion bis heute
verschlafen großbritannien und die usa
agieren vergleichsweise komplett anders
und du sagen sie immer am anfang ist das
der flaschenhals ist dass der
flaschenhals aber das ist nicht der fall
in den usa wenn 1,5 millionen menschen
täglich geimpft und es werden auch
täglich noch mehr die games werden
die amerikaner haben ihm sehr früh mit
18 milliarden wort speed forschung
produktion und impfstoffe darin
investiert und die eu hat drei
milliarden nur da rein es wird
investiert was für ein mißverhältnis
europa hat aber deutlich mehr einwohner
und es ist kein zufall dass in drei
amerikanischen bundesstaaten inzwischen
mehr geimpft worden ist als in ganz
europa und wenn sie jetzt sagen herr
brinkhaus völlig zurecht im strategie
aber so haben sie immer dafür dass bei
den hausärzten jetzt die voraussetzung
geschaffen werden dass die im bericht
sind damit die zügig agieren kann
20 millionen impfen wie jedes jahr
für grippe das muss man aber jetzt
vorbereiten damit das möglich wird
weil damit eine bemerkung machen
pandemie ist weltweit ja was ist
eigentlich mit den globalen süden wann
sollte helfen
wir haben eine sondersituation und
deswegen heben sie die patente auf es
muss global produziert und geimpft
werden patentschutz ist eine impf bremse
und eine mutation stoner kranken
veränderte form zurückkommen das erleben
wir gerade meine damen und herren für
kinder für jugendliche für
alleinerziehende wird der zustand mit
jedem tag unerträglicher
kinder dürfen aber nicht die verlierer
der krise sein
wieviel erziehungswissenschaftlerin und
erziehungswissenschaftler waren
eigentlich bei ihren beratungen dabei
heute eine studie aus hamburg ein
drittel der kinder haben psychische
störungen durch die pandemie
es ist nicht nur das virus das krank
macht es ist auch der umgang mit dem
virus der zunehmend schäden anrichtet
die bürgerinnen und bürger haben die
infektionszahlen mit viel
selbstdisziplin und solidarität nach
unten gebracht ja das gehört immer der
dank wie auch zu den ärzten pflegern da
kann ich mich ihnen anschließen aber sie
haben das auch im vertrauen auf die
politik gemacht und das wurde vielfach
enttäuscht sie haben heute darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass er alte meyer
gestern das schon auf die seite gebracht
hat ehrlich gesagt am 10 februar wie man
die november hilfen sind teilweise noch
nicht ausgezahlt november hilfen wir
haben februar
das ist ein skandal und fragen sie mal
unternehmer und handwerker wie es denen
geht und da sagt auch altmaier sieht
keine fehler und schiebt dass auch die
länder als wenn der kleine fehler
ansieht dann muss er wirklich mal zum
augenarzt gehen meine damen und herren
hunderttausende menschen bangen
ihre selbstständigkeit und ihre
wirtschaftliche existenz warum gibt es
kein unbürokratisches selbstständigen
geld keinen unternehmerlohn die großen
helfen sich vergleichsweise
unkompliziert wie wir immer wieder sehen
und bei den kleinen warten sie monate
lang und meine damen und herren das land
treibt aktuell sozial weiter auseinander
familien und menschen in der
grundsicherung haben sie nach dem
koalitionsbeschluss jetzt 150 euro weg
ja das ist richtig aber ehrlich gesagt
ist natürlich viel zu wenig 12 eur 50 im
monat sind das und ich will mal dazu
sagen am selben tag am selben tag wird
mit stolz verkündet dass die ausgaben
für verteidigung nach nato kriterien bei
53 milliarden sind was ist denn das für
eine relation und da sagen sie noch
stolz ich sage das ist wahnsinn uns
bedrohen keine fremden armeen uns
bedroht ein virus und nichts anderes
meine damen und herren
und wenn wir sehen dass der eigentümer
der supermarktkette lidl sein vermögen
in der krise von 22 milliarden auf 36
milliarden dollar gesteigert hat dann
ist das auch schön wenn wir alle hier
sagen die korona helden denen müssen
gedanken bei denen es auch bei den
arbeitsbedingungen bei den löhnen viel
zu wenig passiert andere haben
milliarden zu wechseln und bei denen
wird wirklich nur gekleckert
nein meine damen und herren aktuell
kommt deutschland als ganzes und nicht
durch die gut gut durch die krise ihre
bilanz ist nicht gut weder bei der
pandemie bekämpfung noch im sozialen
bereich noch bei den wirtschaftshilfen
es muss schluss sein mit
selbstgerechtigkeit wir brauchen
transparenz wir brauchen möglichst eine
planbarkeit ja völlig richtig nicht an
daten aber an mehreren werten damit
zuversicht in unserem land steigt das
ist das dringliche gebot zuversicht muss
wieder wachsen meine damen und herren
herzlichen dank
jetzt hat das wort die
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen hat ringier präsident liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen in frau
bundeskanzlerin es war der 29 oktober da
habe ich an dieser stelle gefordert es
braucht eine langfristige perspektive
damals ging es darum dass die
infektionszahlen stiegen und schon
damals wäre es notwendig gewesen
transparent durchschaubar zu machen wo
wir hin steuern wie wir reagieren und
wem wir wann helfen damit es
zuverlässigkeit damit das vertrauen wird
das könnte man ja sagen hier kann ja das
gesuch wir vertrauen in die
bundesregierung irgendwie egal sein ist
es mir aber nicht warum weil mit weniger
vertrauen erleben wir eben auch dass die
maßnahmen weniger ernst genommen werden
und das ist das problem vor dem wir
heute stehen
und jetzt kann man moment lang lachen
über diese sache mit den friseuren und
ich gönne jedem und jeder hier und
anderswo eine frisur aber könne auch
übrigens den friseurinnen die einnahmen
aber damit ist nichts anderes getan als
dass man das gefühl hat hier soll dem
volk ein bisschen gegeben werden das ist
aber keine strategie
das ist nicht langfristig das ist nicht
klar das ist nicht eindeutig und
deswegen sage ich haben wir weiter
dieses problem und ich will eindeutig
sagen für mich heißen perspektiven
stufen pläne nicht dass wir jetzt öffnen
wir alle wissen doch dass die mutanten
sich längst ausgebreitet haben und
weiter ausbreiten werden in deutschland
es geht nicht um öfter jetzt sondern es
geht darum dass wir allen klarmachen in
unserem land woraufhin wir gemeinsam
arbeiten und dieses woraufhin wir
gemeinsam arbeiten bei weiteren jetzt
vorsicht das haben sie gestern nicht
geliefert und wenn das nicht
funktioniert wenn es nicht funktioniert
in der mpk und wenn die autorität eben
nicht reicht dann meine damen und herren
sage ich hier in diesem haus dann müssen
wir es tun
von hier aus in diesem parlament
beschließen im bundesrat beschließen
dann haben wir eine transparente
eindeutige gemeinsame haltung die
diskutiert ist die transparent ist die
von alternativen lebt meine damen und
herren und das wäre notwendiger denn je
es ist doch ganz klar die wir sind
gewählt als abgeordnete und die menschen
haben uns vertrauen gegeben dass wir
diese dinge auch tatsächlich lösen und
regeln und deswegen rufe ich sie auf
meine kolleginnen und kollegen
ausdrücklich von union und spd in ihren
fraktionen ganz offensichtlich haben es
in der von der cdu fraktion ja auch
lesen können sehr viel ärger gehabt sehr
viel ärger mit der bundesregierung
und es ist eine auseinandersetzung die
ist auch ganz normal da will ich mich
auch gar nicht darüber erheben und es
werden fehler gemacht und diese fehler
muss man thematisieren ich glaube es ist
total richtig aber es reicht doch nicht
hinter verschlossenen türen weil was
durch gestochen wird darüber zu reden
sondern das muss genau hier passieren
damit wir es in zukunft gemeinsam besser
machen meine dann
das betrifft auch umso mehr die
wirtschaftshilfen 100 tage waren die
menschen ohne hilfe und ohne einen cent
einnahmen auf dem konto 100 tage und es
tut mir leid ich kann jetzt heute nicht
hatte du ja rufen weil wir es endlich
mal das programm aufgelegt wird 100 tage
ohne hilfe und die hilfe die kommt ist
ja auch noch längst nicht ausreichend
sie bedeutet für viele solo
selbstständige für künstlerinnen und
künstler eben weiter dass sie nicht
existieren können von dem was sie
eigentlich brauchen und deswegen sage
ich meine damen und herren diese
wirtschaftshilfen dass es ein riesiges
versagen der bundesregierung ein hin-
und herschieben zwischen
wirtschaftsminister und finanzminister
ich verstehe auch nicht warum die spd
weiterhin nicht beim unternehmerlohn
mitmacht geben sie sich einen ruck und
helfen sie den menschen wirklich das hat
auch mit vertrauen zu tun
das hat auch damit zu tun wie wir aus
der krise wieder rauskommen meine damen
und herren
und dann wir haben monate gebraucht bis
es eine regelung zum home office gab und
mir macht sorgen dass wir einerseits
darüber reden wie schaffen wir es denn
mit den kindern nicht kommt leicht dazu
aber immer noch sind heute 20 prozent
mehr menschen auf dem weg zur arbeit und
nicht im home office als im märz
warum ist das so weil sie sorge haben
dass sie in ihrem unternehmen gedisst
werden in ihrem unternehmen womöglich
entlassen werden weil sie nicht
mitmachen und deswegen ist es auch eine
politische frage ob ihr klar und
eindeutig sagen home office musst jetzt
gemacht werden auch damit kinder in die
schule und die kitas geöffnet werden
können mein gedanken
und ich schnell ich will genau genau
dazu etwas sagen nach einem jahr kann
die können wir nicht mehr sagen schule
auf oder schule zu und ich verstehe
nicht warum man sich darauf nicht
einigen konnte gestern ich verstehe vor
allen dingen nicht warum es nicht
gemeinsame voraussetzungen dafür gibt
dass an schulen und kitas sicherheit
herrscht für die kinder und für die
erzieherin und für die lehrerin der
brinkhaus
die erste voraussetzung die müssten
jetzt ja gemeinsam schaffen dass es für
wirklich für alle schnell es gibt dass
es wirklich ein luftfilter programm gibt
es auch ankommt weil wir nicht davon
ausgehen kann dass das irgendwie dann
alles doch im april vorbei ist aber das
andere da bin ich ja sehr beiden wo ist
denn das große programm mit einem fonds
mit einem bundesfonds was dafür sorgt
dass wir jetzt herausfinden welche
kinder brauchen besonders viel hilfe wo
ist denn das wo ist denn das programm wo
wir dafür sorgen dass wir tatsächlich
feststellen welche kinder brauchen
besondere hilfe die wir zum teil ein
jahr nicht gesehen haben die waren nicht
in der not betreuung die waren nirgendwo
und deswegen sage ich ihnen ganz
eindeutig herr brinkhaus bitte lassen
sie uns das zusammen machen ohne sich
gegenseitig an zu meckern
das haben die kinder in diesem land
überhaupt nicht verdient was haben die
kinder in diesem land nicht verdient
ganz im gegenteil was was müssen wir
eigentlich tun
wir müssen doch jetzt sagen konzepte für
die schulen sind da so dass man sicher
dort arbeiten kann und dort wo es in der
schule nicht geht und wo auch der
wechsel unterricht noch nicht reicht
dann lassen sie das was an fantasie
schon längst da ist in lüneburg wird in
der kirche unterrichtet und in
wachenroth hinter rot einem kleinen ort
eine türen spanischen grenze wird im
gemeindehaus unterrichtet weil die leute
sagen wir können das mit sicherheit hin
bekommen und deswegen bevor man sich
auch die friseure einig dann bitte mit
aller kraft dafür sorgen dass schule
sicher
drinnen und schüler für eltern und kita
erzieherin auch tatsächlich stattfinden
kann meine damen und herren
diese anstrengungen davon hängt sehr
viel ab und ich finde es ja sehr
bemerkenswert frau bundeskanzlerin dass
sie auch öffentlich gesagt haben ich
konnte mich da nicht durchsetzen
wo sie sich aber hätten durchsetzen
können das ist bei der bereitstellung
der voraussetzung das finde ich nach wie
vor den zentralen punkt dazu gehört
übrigens auch dass wir sehr direkte
hilfe brauchen
viele dieser kinder leiden jetzt am
meisten an der pandemie aber womöglich
eben auch am längsten nämlich dann wenn
sie schon längst vorbei ist und deswegen
brauchen sie jetzt auch unmittelbare
hilfe
also von mir aus den studenten der den
flüchtlingskindern hilft und die dann
hinterher trotzdem noch sagen können ich
will ingenieuren werden oder ärztin oder
die großmutter die im feuerwehrhaus
erklärt wie das mit dem kegeln und mit
den klaren ist ja warum denn eigentlich
nicht wir könnten sehr viel mehr wenn
wir mit sehr viel mehr fantasie
unterwegs wären und die künstlerinnen
und künstler können am ende sogar noch
im museum oder in der galerie dafür
sorgen dass kinder nicht einfach zu
hause sitzen gelassen werden vom
sitzenbleiben zu reden ist ebenfalls der
fall schon meine damen und herren
diese pandemie wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen ja und gleichzeitig sollten
wir uns jetzt mit der frage
auseinandersetzen was kommt eigentlich
danach was kommt eigentlich danach nur
dann werden wir es auch wirklich
schaffen dass hierdurch zu halten also
nach dem log daum und dem lockdown wann
kommt eigentlich open ab das klingt ein
bisschen nach aufbruch das klingt für
manche sogar ein bisschen nachtanzen und
lassen sie uns gemeinsam auch an diesem
aufbruch arbeiten
wir sehen in der beschränkung was uns
was bedeutet begegnung nähe kontakt
kinokultur clubs wir sehen was machbar
ist wenn gemeinsam gehandelt wird
ja das sehen wir tatsächlich wenn sich
alle gemeinsam anstrengen wir sehen was
möglich wäre und wir haben nicht nur
diese eine krise die klimakrise schläft
weiter nicht
und die arten krise die stillste von
allen eben auch nicht und wenn wir bei
dir einen sehr viel geduld brauchen
es ist bei den beiden anderen so dass
wir sehr viel und sehr schnell handeln
müssen und meine damen und herren auch
dass auch das von diesem ort aus diese
20er jahre könnten solche 20er jahre
werden wenn wir zeigen dass wir krisen
tatsächlich gemeinsam bewältigen mit
allem was uns zur verfügung steht mit
aller kraft und immer mit den menschen
gemeinsam und zwar von hier aus nicht
top down sondern von hier aus mit
demokratischer beteiligung und
vielleicht können wir dann irgendwann
gemeinsam darauf tanzen vielen dank
welche geräte ist die kollegin bärbel
bas spd herr präsident meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ein jahr leben wir jetzt mit dieser
pandemie und versuchen sie zu bekämpfen
ich sag deshalb versuchen weil wir damit
noch lange nicht am ende sind wir haben
aber im gegensatz zu vielen die heute
hier vor mir gesprochen haben uns
dennoch weiter entwickelt es ist nicht
so dass wir nicht ein jahr auch aus
dieser pandemie schon gelernt haben
wir haben impfstoffe wir haben mit dem
impfen begonnen mehr als zwei millionen
menschen sind schon geimpft das ist noch
lange nicht ausreichend das wissen wir
alle aber das sind wichtige schritte die
wir jetzt begonnen haben die korona app
ist vorhin angesprochen worden der
linken hat gesagt sie ist eingeführt hat
sich überhaupt nicht weiterentwickelt
das stimmt nicht
es hat mehrere updates gegeben ein
kontakt tagebuch was gefordert wurde ist
jetzt drin wir haben aktuelle zahlen
drin aber ich sage auch ich sage auch da
ist noch luft nach oben keine frage
denn wenn wir über öffnungs strategien
reden kann die app natürlich auch wenn
man ins restaurant geht oder in
veranstaltungen zusätzlichen mehrwert
haben wenn man dann die
kontaktvermittlung auch damit nutzt
datenschutzgerecht das ist möglich und
deshalb gibt es natürlich eine
weiterentwicklung an der stelle
und ich will auf diese öffnung strategie
und die perspektive gehen viele menschen
haben sich von dieser veranstaltung
gestern der kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten eine perspektive
gewünscht
wir alle wünschen uns eine perspektive
und die stufen pläne die vorliegen das
ist ja mittlerweile nicht nur so dass
einzelne die vorgestellt haben es gibt
einstufen pläne die haben wir gestern
hier im parlament diskutiert aber es
gibt auch stufen plänen der länder
und natürlich haben wir uns gewünscht
dass dann nicht nur der bereich der
friseure für die branche freut es mich
aber dass nicht nur dass dabei rauskommt
das ist durchaus ein punkt wo wir
perspektiven geben müssen aber ich sage
auch perspektive zu geben es nicht so
einfach wenn wir nicht wissen wie die
mutation und das ist ein
wissenschaftlicher begriff auch wenn der
steht dieser begriff schwerfällt
mutationen sich unterschwellig
ausbreiten dann ist es ein großes
problem dass wir nicht wissen was eine
richtige zahl für eine perspektive oder
eine öffnung strategie ist und das
treibt uns ja alle um
ich würde gerne sofort alles auf und ich
würde auch gern sofort ein stufenplan
beschließen wobei die die vorliegen ja
auch schon sehr unterschiedlich sind
aber wir müssen uns doch klar machen
dass wir eben nicht wissen wie die
ausbreitungen weitergehen wird und ich
will noch mal daran erinnern das kommt
mir hier zu kurz für aller debatte wir
waren im sommer soweit wir haben alle
schulen auf gemacht gab
präsenzunterricht alle lokale alle
kulturen haben wie der erste
veranstaltung macht es gab genug
konzepte und trotzdem sind uns die
infektionszahlen entglitten so und die
sind uns entgegen im oktober erschossen
sie hoch das wissen wir doch gar nicht
ob sich im sommer war das liegt einfach
daran wenn zu viele kontakte möglich
sind hat das virus die chance sich
auszubreiten und wenn mutationen dazu
kommen die sind normal dass sie dazu
kommen wenn die aber dazu dazu kommen
dass sie möglicherweise impfstoffe die
wir jetzt haben unmöglich machen oder
dass wir erst wieder zeit brauchen sie
zu verändern
dann stehen wir in
der nächsten in den nächsten drei
monaten wieder an einem punkt wo wir
wieder alles zu machen müssen und ich
sag mal das schadet kindern und eltern
genauso und uns allen
dieses auf und ab das ist doch das große
problem
und jetzt zu sagen wir machen jetzt
schöne stufen pläne alles super aber wir
dürfen trotzdem nicht vergessen es muss
irgendwelche zahlen seien an die mal
eine perspektive dann auch knüpft und
natürlich müssen wir an der stelle wenn
es jetzt zum beispiel seit sommer gibt
es bessere schnelltests demnächst kommen
selbst test- und heimtest dann muss man
das auch an eine strategie binden und
die fehlten übrigens auch ich möchte
auch dass selbst testen dazu gehören das
sich heimtest zu hause mache wenn sie
eine gute qualität haben aber doch nicht
einfach nur so wir schmeißen sie auf dem
markt sondern es muss doch verbunden sei
mit einer perspektive für
kulturschaffende für öffnung von
restaurants für kneipen für alles
mögliche dafür muss doch auch so eine
test strategie weiterentwickelt werden
und das gehört dazu für mich zu einem
stufenplan und daran muss gearbeitet
werden und dass wir jetzt die schulen
und kitas wieder in die verantwortung
der länder gegeben haben
ja das ist föderalismus und sie sind
dafür zuständig es macht mir trotzdem
sorgen das will ich ganz ernsthaft sagen
weil ich nicht weiß wie die einzelnen
länder damit umgehen werden
das wird unterschiedlich sein und in
nordrhein westfalen das ist das
bundesland wo ich herkomme war das
bisher nicht besonders glücklich wie man
die schulen darauf vorbereitet hat wie
sie damit umgehen sollen bin präsenz
wechsel unterricht kreative ideen wurden
kreative ideen ideen herr linder wurden
da unterdrückt in nordrhein westfalen so
und das ist doch ein punkt wo man wo man
sagt ich sag ja das mache ich mir sorgen
sie preisen den föderalismus an ich habe
da große sorgen dass nicht andere länder
im vergleich des bundesgebietes wieder
abgehangen werden dass nicht genug
nachhilfe stattfindet dass man nicht gut
genug vorbereitet ist auf die öffnung
ich habe großes vertrauen dass die
länder das schaffen
ich will nur meine sorge sagen dass das
es jetzt auch gut vorbereitet werden
soll dass die schulen das jetzt gut
vorbereiten dass die länder das gut
vorbereiten und erst dann sollte
purple schritt für schritt geöffnet
werden das ist mein appell nochmal in
die richtung auch derer die jetzt die
verantwortung dafür übernommen haben
dass es wichtig für schülerinnen und
schüler für lehrerinnen und lehrer
das hat auch dass das auch so
funktioniert dass wir alle damit auch
sicher umgehen können und die
infektionszahlen so niedrig bleiben wie
bisher das ist ein erfolg den wir
durchaus heute auch noch mal sagen
dürfen die zahlen den kontinuierlich
runter und ich wünsche mir dass es
weiterhin nach unten geht denn damit ist
uns allen geholfen herzlichen dank
nächster redner ist der kollege
sebastian münzenmaier afd
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren die folgen von angst können
weit größer sein als die durch das virus
selbst mit diesen worten eröffnete jens
spahn am 4 märz 2020 eine
bundestagsdebatte zum corona virus und
heute sind seine worte treffen da denn
je diese bundesregierung versetzt
vorsätzlich ein ganzes volk in angst
meinungsvielfalt ist im umfeld der
kanzlerin nicht erwünscht stattdessen
sollen merkels haus und hof
wissenschaftler wie drosten wähler oder
bringt man politisch gewollte panikmache
möglichst wissenschaftlich an hauchen
der inzidenz wert von 50 war noch nie
wirklich wissenschaftlich begründet und
wird jetzt über nacht einfach mal so auf
35 gesenkt was machen wir denn
eigentlich im märz liebe frau
bundeskanzlerin wenn wir uns ihren
geliebten inzidenz wird dann wieder
angenähert haben wird dann eine neue
zahl gewürfelt oder entdecken sie
irgendeine neue noch schlimmere noch
tödlichere noch aggressivere mutation
aus papua neuguinea oder sonstwo auf der
welt
ich bin mir sicher in ihrem locker und
faschismus fällt ihnen irgendetwas 1
ihre devise lautet costes wasser wolle
dieser lockdown muss unbedingt bleiben
es gibt es gibt mittlerweile zahlreiche
namhafte wissenschaftler und virologen
die in studien die wirksamkeit eines
londons anzweifeln
es gibt alternativ vorschläge
beispielsweise aus unserer fraktion die
einen kurswechsel und einen besseren
schutz der risikogruppen fordern es gibt
zahlreiche kritische stimmen die den
sogenannten kollateralschaden ihrer
politik an machen aber was soll's angela
merkel verschanzt sich weiterhin mit
ihrem ministerpräsidenten stammtisch im
kanzleramt und während bodo ramelow
candy crosstalk verzogen sie liebe frau
bundeskanzlerin die zukunft eines ganzen
landes meine damen und herren
betrachten wir doch mal die harten
fakten
es gibt momentan 164.000 am corona virus
infiziert den ganz deutschland dazu
zählen auch die sogenannten symptomlos
erkrankung früher nannte man das wohl
gesund aber selbst wenn ich jetzt ihrer
logik folge und diese infizierten zahlen
betrachtet
dann sprechen wir über 0,197 der
menschen in deutschland die infizierte
0,197 prozent währenddessen sind aber
knapp zehn prozent der menschen in
deutschland arbeitslos oder in
kurzarbeit tendenz eher steigend
hunderttausende von selbstständigen
künstlern und freiberuflern stehen kurz
vor dem ruin
die insolvenzwelle rollt noch auf uns zu
und wird nicht nur tausende kleine und
mittelständische betriebe unter sich
begraben
sie wird auch die strukturen die
innenstädte unseres landes verändern
der mittelstand hat deutschland einst
groß gemacht aber der mittelstand wird
von dieser bundesregierung sehenden
auges an die wand gefahren meine damen
und herren
aber sie verzocken ja nicht nur den
wohlstand unseres landes sondern auch
die zukunft unserer kinder in der
aktuellen kops ii studie klagen 85
prozent der befragten kinder über eine
seelische belastung die sorgen und
ängste haben zugenommen auch depressive
symptome sind verstärkt zu beobachten
und vom bildungs verlust dank
geschlossener schulen spreche ich doch
gar nicht liebe frau bundeskanzlerin was
sie anrichten wird unser land auf
jahrzehnte beschädigen
aber statt nach lösungen zu suchen wird
von dieser regierung einfach panik
geschürt
haben sie sich mal die wortwahl von
merkels entourage pünktlich vor den
regelmäßigen klingen runden angeschaut
da wird mit übertreibungen um sich
geworfen die der geneigte hörer er aus
hollywood film mit untergangsszenarien
kennt der dirigent des panikorchesters
karl lauterbach warnt vor dem turbo
virus rk ii chef lothar wieder spricht
davon dass das virus einen boost
erhalten habe und die noko wie tisch ist
in melanie brinkmann beklagt ich zitiere
die mutante aus großbritannien und
andere werden uns überrennen
das virus hat einen raketenantrieb
bekommen es geht nur noch darum können
wir den siegeszug der varianten
hinauszögern und zeitgewinn zitat ende
diese dumpfe kriegs rhetorik erinnert an
dunkle zeiten und ich kann ihnen allen
nur zurufen stoppen sie endlich diese
panikmache schützen sie die
risikogruppen und beenden sie den lock
down some der unverhältnismässigen
folgen meine damen und herren unsere fdp
fraktion
kämpft mittlerweile seit monaten mit
hilfe von klugen ideen anträgen und
vorschlägen für eine politik der
vernunft und vor allem der
verhältnismäßigkeit
wir wehren uns gegen ihren wahnsinn und
wir werden auch weiterhin hier im
bundestag alles dafür tun unsere leute
und unser land vor ihren ihren ideen zu
schützen
aber leider sind uns teilweise die hände
gebunden weil die vereinte altparteien
front von den tiefroten sed-erben bis
hin zu den gelben wände hensen diese
kanzlerin stützt und dieses land immer
weiter richtung abgrund führt deshalb
möchte ich sie meine damen und herren an
den bildschirm da draußen direkt
ansprechen wir brauchen ihre
unterstützung wenn sie in diesem land
wirklich etwas ändern wollen dann wählen
sie die einzige echte oppositionspartei
und am 14 märz können sie sich in
rheinland-pfalz und in baden-württemberg
für freiheit und vernunft anstatt für
angst und aktionismus entscheiden ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
alexander dobrindt cdu/csu ich der
nächste redner
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja in den
letzten wochen hat man das deutlich
gespürt dass jeder tag des verzichts
jeder tag der kontakt beschränkungen
jeder tag des schließens verlangt den
menschen und der wirtschaft in unserem
land unglaublich viel ab und gerade auch
in diesen letzten tagen und wochen hat
man festgestellt dass ein wunsch ja
immer stärker wird in unserer
gesellschaft der wunsch nach normalität
und genau das ist auch der grund warum
wir uns gerade in einer der kritischsten
phase nach der pandemie befinden weil
wir auf der einen seite die situation
haben dass der virus an einer
weggabelung steht bei der noch nicht
absehbar ist welchen weg er geht um den
von uns erhofften die instanzen weiter
runter oder einen anderen mit steigenden
insolvenzen durch die mutation und auf
der anderen seite stellen wir fest dass
die wirtschaftlichen die sozialen folgen
des lok bei uns deutlich auf die
stimmung sich auswirkungen die stimmung
angespannter wird bedrückender und ja
auch das muss man sagen bei einigen
begegnungen kann man das inzwischen ganz
persönlich feststellen ob das bis höhere
oder einzelhändler oder andere sind es
gibt auch eine stimmung die verzweifelte
wird und darauf muss die politik
reagieren und die reaktion heißt
konsequent und perspektiven miteinander
verbinden und dass es die auftrag und
die aufgabe und das ist auch das was in
unserer entscheidung von gestern
vorkommt wir haben klare perspektiven
gegeben für wirtschaftshilfen für
impfungen aber auch eine klare
perspektive für den einstieg in den
ausstieg aus dem block da meine damen
und herren
die beschlüsse von gestern
sie versuchen das grundprinzip von
konsequenz und perspektiven kollegen
bringt gestalten sie eine zwischenfrage
nein danke bieten es gibt momentan an
der stelle auch eine ganze reihe von
fragen und auch kritikern der zahl die
gestern so eine große rolle gespielt hat
nämlich die inzidenz zahlen von 35 und
da ist auch der hinweis ganz offen
gesprochen dass es sich um eine zahl
handelt die ja bereits im
infektionsschutzgesetz sich befindet was
stimmt der ist für viele als erklärung
nicht ganz ausreichend und es wird auch
heute klar man fähig zu sehr stark doch
dieser zahl von 50 die man aus den
vergangenen wochen und monaten sehr gut
kennt und deswegen hier noch einen satz
auch zur plan erklärung dazu die 50 war
immer die zahl wo man bei wachsender
infektion den einstieg in den lockdown
gewählt hat sie kann nicht gleichzeitig
die zahl des ausstiegs aus dem lot down
sein
ansonsten hätten wir einen andauernden
achterbahn effekt eine berg und talfahrt
zwischen lockdown und lockerungen und
deswegen muss die zahl der lockerungen
deutlich unter der 50 liegen damit wir
unsere erfolge in der stelle nicht
verspielen meine damen und herren wir
haben festgestellt dass der druck
auf die forderung oder die forderung und
der druck dazu auf die öffnung der
schulen sehr sehr groß geworden ist und
ich hoffe dass diese maßnahme die die
länder an der stelle ergreifen jetzt der
entwicklung der senkung der infektions
kurve nicht zu sehr entgegen wirken ich
verstehe dass der druck groß ich
verstehe das home-office kinderbetreuung
und homeschooling eine enorme
doppelbelastung auch für die familien
bedeutet aber ich habe zweifel dass
diese maßnahme der schuleröffnung zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt eine richtige ist
unabhängig davon wie man diese frage
beantwortet steht für mich auf jeden
fall fest wir müssen alles daran setzen
dass diese maßnahmen nicht weitere
perspektiven der öffnungen der
wirtschaft verbaut meine damen und
herren das ist der auftrag jetzt auch
wenn man diese maßnahmen redet bei den
wirtschafts hilfen es ist richtig und
gut dass diese wirtschaft hilfe drei
jetzt anlaufen beantragt werden können
es ist wichtig dass jetzt schnell und
unbürokratisch dann auch zur
abschlagszahlungen führen und wir werden
das auch feststellen wie schnell diese
abschlagszahlungen dann auch laufen ich
weise aber darauf hin es geht bei ganz
ganz vielen auch gerade bei den
selbstständigen bei denjenigen die ein
geschäft betreiben es geht bei ganz ganz
vielen um ein lebenswerk und deswegen
sind die emotionen auch ganz besonders
groß an dieser stelle und es wird am
ende konstellationen geben die auch
durch dieses raster der
überbrückungshilfe 3
möglicherweise durchfallen deswegen
meine dringende bitte auch an den
finanzminister
wir erwarten dass es auch einen
härtefall gibt herr finanzminister der
dann da stützt wo lebenswerke auf dem
spiel stehen und wo die algorithmen der
überbrückungshilfe nicht greifen auch
das ist eine notwendige maßnahme und die
wirtschaft an dieser stelle zu stärken
ja wer was ist betont worden dass impfen
ist der weg aus der krise um die
ansteckungen zu verringern um schwere
krankheitsverläufe einzudämmen und
todesfälle auch zu vermeiden es ist der
weg in das normale leben zurück und ja
auch da hat es fehler gegeben
das hatte fehlleistungen und
fehleinschätzungen auch gerade in
brüssel auch in der kommission gegeben
aber es hat auch eine verfehlte debatte
in deutschland gegeben eine
fehlgeleitete button über den
sogenannten impf nationalismus meine
damen und herren wir brauchen keine
debatte über internationalismus wir
brauchen eine debatte über mut zur
souveränität bei der frage der
versorgung von medikamenten und
impfstoffen das ist die aufgabe unserer
debatte und sehr geehrter herr war
sie haben wahrscheinlich keine zeit mit
dieser diskussion zu folgen
trotzdem sei ihnen der seite hinweis an
der stelle gestattet sie haben hier als
erstes in einer art bewunderung
gegenüber den usa
diese als gelungenes beispiel beim
impfen beschrieben dann aber beklagt
dass der globale süden zu wenig
impfstoff hat sie müssen sich an der
stelle mal entscheiden weil abgesehen
davon dass die bewunderung für die usa
von ihrer seite ein vorgang an sich ist
die usa hat beim impfen eine ganz ganz
klare devise
und die heißt america first und die wird
sogar noch mit kriegsrecht durchgesetzt
dass sie das bewundert das ist in der
tat ein vorgang
wir brauchen eine souveränitäts
offensive auch im bereich der impfstoffe
der medikamentenversorgung der
bundesfinanzminister sieht wochenende
gesagt ich will das wieder dass wir
wieder die apotheke der welt werden
ich stimme ihnen da ausdrücklich zu aber
dann müssen auch die notwendigen
finanzmittel zur verfügung gestellt
werden um das zu erreichen dann muss ein
souveränitäts programm für impfstoff und
für medikamente forschung und produktion
in deutschland und europa eingerichtet
werden stellen sie dieses programm vor
und dann haben sie unsere unterstützung
herzlichen dank
nächste reden wenn ich die kollegin
nadine schön cdu csu
sehr geehrter habt das sident liebe
kollegen kollegen noch nie den ganzen
wochen und monaten der krise lagen die
nerven so plank ich denke das spüren wir
alle gerade die familien sind wirklich
am limit und vieles sagen wir können
nicht mehr
wir können nicht mehr das sagen die
eltern die homeschooling kinderbetreuung
vereinbaren müssen mit der arbeit klar
es gibt den lohnersatz aber viele fühlen
sich auch ihren kolleginnen und kollegen
verpflichtet oder arbeiten selbst ins
system solle manchen berufe als lehrerin
als lehrer als pflegekräfte
wir können nicht mehr das sagen auch
sogar kinder die gerne wieder ihre
freundinnen freunde sehen würden die
gerne wieder mit anderen lernen würden
die gerne andere treffen und das gefühl
haben sich adäquat auf ihre prüfungen
vorbereiten zu können
und wir können nicht mehr sagen auch
ganz viele alleinstehende ob jung oder
alt die sagen ich kann nicht mal meine
beste freundin in den arm nehmen das
fehlt mir so sehr wie gerne würde man
jetzt sagen schluss jetzt wir haben
genug es reicht der wunsch nach einem
normalen oder einem normalen laden leben
er ist so kloos und deshalb ist es
richtig dass auch gestern über
perspektiven gesprochen wurde und dass
wir hoffnung haben aber hoffnung macht
nur dann sinn wenn sie nicht direkt
wieder enttäuscht wird und perspektiven
sind nur dann gut wenn sie wirklich
tragfähig sind
und leider ist das virus noch da und bei
manchen reden heute in der debatte habe
ich mich gefragt in welcher welt leben
sie denn das virus ist noch da wir haben
kein lineares wir haben grundsätzlich
wächst dass wir das exponentiell
können froh sein dass die zahlen geht es
endlich nach unten gehen und das können
wir doch nicht verspielen und ich
erinnere mich noch sehr gut
als wir im november den lockdown leicht
gemacht haben und dachten mit hygiene
konzept in maske und abstand kommen weil
er irgendwie gut durch und die wahrheit
war das hat nicht geklappt die zahlen
sind gestiegen
ich erinnere mich noch gut als er im
dezember nachrichten aus sachsen hatten
wo es hieß dass in krankenhäusern
übertraf noch gedanken nachgedacht wird
und ich erinnere mich an die panik der
menschen die dann bei steigenden
infektionszahlen sagen wir haben angst
um unsere angehörigen die vorbelastet
sind die noch nicht geimpft sind wir
haben aus dass das virus um sich greift
aufforderten folgeschäden
darüber wird doch gar nicht gesprochen
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir die
zahlen nach unten bringen und dass wir
die öffnung erst dann machen wenn wir
ein und sockel wert erreicht haben der
nicht dazu führt dass die zahlen danach
gleich wieder explodieren
und es ist richtig das sage ich als
familienpolitikerin dass wir mit den
familien zuerst anfangen das wäre mit
den kindergärten den kitas und schulen
zuerst anfangen
aber auch hier gilt mit system und mit
verstand und so das test konzepte
vorliegen bevor man öffnet es reicht
nicht wenn die nur auf dem papier da
sind und es reicht auch nicht lieber
frage wenn sie sagen es gibt bald alten
tipps noch gibt es die eigenen tests
nicht und deshalb müssen die kommunen
test konzepte schaffen damit wir die
schulen so öffnen können das wird von
dort keine gefahr ausgeht für die
schülerin nun versetzt wie ihre eltern
wäre angehörigen
für uns alle und das ist hart und es ist
noch ein bisschen arbeit aber ich traue
den kommunen nicht traut den landrat in
schulen zu dass sie das schaffen
und es ist ja so viel geschafft worden
schauen sie doch was in den schulen
schon passiert da gehört auch mein
herzlicher dank ball an die lehrerinnen
und lehrer was die möglich gemacht haben
in den letzten wochen und monaten
das ist doch wahnsinn da wird sich
gekümmert und jeden einen shooter werten
digitale konzepte geschaffen und mein
appell ist auch kalender ich habe es
nicht verstanden dass ihre fdp
kultusministerin in nrw kann sagte bei
einer schule die sagte wir können hybrid
arbeiten dass das das nicht möglich war
lassen wir doch die individuellen
konzepte vor ort zu lassen wir doch die
kreativität der menschen auch ihren
entfaltungsspielraum und dann finden wir
doch viel bessere lösungen und deshalb
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist gut dass wir mit den schulen
anfangen wir müssen die kinder in den
blick nehmen denn es geht auch um
pädagogische und soziale folgen aber mit
sinn und verstand dafür abonniert ich
dass es unsere aufgabe in den nächsten
monaten den nächsten wochen vielen dank
so einer 2
bündnis 90 zu bündnis
vielen dank herr präsident ich möchte
mich noch mal auf den kollegen dobrindt
beziehen sie hatten sehr viel zu
es war mein fehler dass ich ihnen die
vorher nicht die ziemlich nicht mehr
gegeben danke danke dass es dass es
jetzt funktioniert da ich doch sehr gern
zum kollegen dobrindt sprechen wollte
sie hatten die wirtschaftshilfen
angesprochen und es stimmt ja dass bei
den november dezember hilfen haben
einige betriebe profitiert es gibt
allerdings auch betriebe die haben noch
keinen einzigen cent gesehen und es sind
des schmerzmittels oberfranken als
bayerin besonders und sie als bayer
sicher auch ausgerechnet brauerei
gaststätten die einziges vergehen ist
sie braun selbst bier teilweise seit
jahrhunderten und schenken das in ihrer
gaststätte aus deswegen bekommen sie als
miss betriebe keine hilfen
es gebe eine ganz einfache lösung für
dieses problem sie stellen die
brauereigaststätte mit anderen
gaststätten gleich es geht um ganz ganz
wenige betriebe und ich rede jetzt nicht
von überbrückungshilfe drei sondern ich
rede vom jetzt von der jetzigen
situation diese betriebe sind jetzt in
not daher meine frage an sie schaffen
sie es als koalition noch diese änderung
hin zu kriegen oder lassen sie die
betriebe den bach runtergehen
herr kollege dobrindt möchten sie
antworten
dass wir haben das wort
sehr geehrte frau kollegin warum sorgt
hier für ein bisschen heiterkeit dass
sie sich für brauereien einsetzt nicht
alle das ausdrücklich nicht sagt es ganz
deutlich dass es sich hier um ein thema
handelt bei dem nachbesserungsbedarf
besteht wir haben festgestellt dass im
bereich der mischbetrieb es hier zu
einer nachteiligen behandlung von
brauerei gaststätten kommt damit auch zu
den nachteiligen behandlung von
traditionsbetriebe die oftmals seit
jahrzehnten oder vielleicht schon seit
jahrhunderten unterwegs sind wir wollen
genau dieses thema lösen
deswegen sind wir in intensiven debatten
mit dem wirtschaft und dem
finanzministerium dazu da für eine
adäquate lösung zu finden ich halte das
ausdrücklich für geboten vielen dank
jetzt hat das wort die kollegin
stabilität war spd
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren die heutige debatte offenbart
noch einmal eindrücklich das enorme
spannungsverhältnis mit dem wir alle in
diesen tagen und wochen zurechtkommen
müssen wir sehen einerseits dass unsere
gemeinsamen anstrengungen der
zurückliegenden wochen ihre wirkungen
zeichen die zu jahresbeginn festgelegten
verstärkten maßnahmen zu kontakt
beschränken waren wichtig es ist uns
damit gelungen die zahl der
neuinfektionen mit dem corona wir uns
deutlich zu reduzieren
in fast allen bundesländern liegen wir
heute bei einer inzidenz von deutlich
unter 100 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohnern
trotzdem sind die todesfälle noch viel
zu hoch und noch immer arbeiten die
intensivstationen an bzw
oftmals noch über die belastungsgrenze
da die patienten zahlen nur langsam
zurückgehen
meine damen und herren die gegenwärtige
situation und die schutzmaßnahmen
verlangen uns allen privat beruflich
sozial und ökonomisch viel ab und auch
wenn wir alle irgendwie genervt sind und
ein ende des lockouts herbeisehnen zeigt
der jüngste deutschlandtrend nach wie
vor eine 75 prozentige zustimmung zu den
maßnahmen die meisten wissen
die beste waffe gegen das virus ist in
keinerlei chance zu geben sich zu
verbreiten und dafür dass die
überwiegende mehrheit diesen weg
solidarisch mitglied möchte ich mich
ganz ausdrücklich bedanken die mine
kommen die mainzer machen wir schritt
für schritt boden gut im kampf gegen wir
sehen deutliche fortschritte zum
beispiel bei den impfungen elf monate
nach dem ersten fall in deutschland
konnten wir mit dem impfen beginnen
das ist eine herausragende leistung
unserer wissenschaft ein großteil der
bewohnerinnen und bewohner der senioren-
und pflegeeinrichtungen als eine
besonders gefährdete personengruppen hat
mittlerweile
die erstimpfung und zum teil auch die
zeit impfung erhalten und es ist gut
dass sich bund und länder ergänzen zur
nationalen strategie auf einen hilfsplan
verständigt haben die
impfstoffversorgung das planverfahren
planbarkeit ist der schlüssel zum erfolg
und wir werden in deutschland in den
kommenden wochen deutlich mehr impfstoff
zur verfügung haben und da muss
sichergestellt sein dass dieser
impfstoff dann auch zügig in den
bundesländern verimpft wird und deshalb
ist es gut dass sich die konferenz gäste
auch mit diesen organisationsfragen
beschäftigt hat wir sehen wie sie im
fortschritte beim testen die
laborkapazitäten beim pcr test in
zwischenzeitlich auf über zwei millionen
ausgebaut eine wahnsinnsleistung unsere
labore und auch die anti den schnelltest
sind mittlerweile ein fester bestandteil
in vielen einrichtungen
sie ermöglichen ein wichtiges stück an
mehr teilhabe und sobald die antigen
schnelltest nach dem notwendigen
prüfungen durch das bundesamt für
arzneimittel auch für die
selbstanwendung zugelassen sind werden
wir einen weiteren wichtigen baustein
zur verfügung haben der die test
strategie sinnvoll ergänzen wird
das alles sind gute nachrichten
und genau hier zeigt sich aber der
ambivalenz und frau derzeitigen
situation ja wir haben boden gut gemacht
aber trotzdem sind wir noch lange nicht
am ziel
vor allem die verbreitung der virus
mutationen brasilianische
südafrikanische britische bereitet große
sorgen dass die britische variante b 11
7 verbreitet sich rasant in deutschland
sie ist sehr viel infektiöse und
aggressiver als der wild virus und auch
wenn unsere neue infektionen insgesamt
deutlich sinken müssen wir doch zur
kenntnis nehmen dass sich der andere der
mutationen darüber im zweistellig
prozentbereich vermehrt und das bedeutet
im klartext dass jedes geringsten
nachlassen in die kontakt beschränkungen
denn wir uns ein exponentielles wachstum
ermöglicht und diese chance meine damen
und herren dürfen wir ihn auf keinen
fall geben
und deshalb ist es richtig dass die
bundesländer gestern verabredet haben
erst bei einer stabilen sieben tage ins
events von 35 weitere öffnungen zu
ermöglichen
und dennoch sage ich hier auch ich
bedauere es dass es der kanzlerin und
den ländervertretern nicht gelungen ist
zum einen im bildungsbereich für mehr
einheitlichkeit zu erreichen und zum
anderen zu einem konkreten fahrplan
natürlich immer orientiert am
infektionsgeschehen sich darauf zu
verabreden
wir brauchen eine belastbare strategie
die den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
unternehmen der gastronomie den
kulturschaffenden klare und transparente
planungs respektiven gibt und zwar
sowohl für den fall einer verbesserung
der lage als auch für den fall dass das
infektionsgeschehen sich erneut
verschlechtert
meine damen und herren liebe bürgerinnen
und bürger der erde kollegen wir haben
doch einen langen weg vor uns aber
schrittweise kommen wir weiter wenn wir
alle bereit sind mitzuhelfen bei
lockerungen diszipliniert sind bei
kurzfristigen anstiegen uns wieder
zurück nehmen lassen sie uns diesen weg
weiterhin gemeinsam und solidarisch
gehen und corona die stirn bieten
bleiben sie gesund
nächster redner ist der kollege andreas
jung cdu csu präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der bundestag das ist der
ort an dem über diese maßnahmen
diskutiert wird und diskutiert werden
muss und hier muss auch gestritten
werden
das gehört bei einer solchen debatte
dazu hier wird auch entschieden wir
haben das mit grundlegenden entscheidung
zu allen schritten auch getan ralph
brinkhaus hingewiesen auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz ich will aber
doch und gerade wenn sie mir das zu
rufen auch in ihre richtung sagen man
kann über vieles streiten aber über
bestimmte fakten eben nicht dass wir in
dieser schweren situation sind im land
das liegt nicht an der politik das liegt
daran dass ein virus weltweit in einer
weltweiten pandemie über uns gekommen
ist dass wir länger in einer schwierigen
situation sind liegt daran dass sich
eine mutation des sich mutationen die
bildet haben das ist das was ich
beschwer was uns beschwer macht und dann
kann man darüber diskutieren und
streiten wie man darauf reagiert und
bietet verwechseln sie nicht ursache und
wirkung
und zweitens ich erinnere mich dass es
der london begonnen wurde wir ähnliche
debatten in diesem haus hatten kann man
auch jetzt über vieles diskutieren aber
nicht darüber dass es in einer anderen
situation sind als im dezember
die situation ist besser geworden die
zahlen sind runter gegangen deshalb sind
wir jetzt in einer situation in der wir
auch wieder über die nächsten schritte
zur lockerung sprechen können weil
maßnahmen konsequent umgesetzt würden
weil die bürgerinnen und bürger in ihrer
ganz großen mehrheit mit akzeptanz und
mit vorsicht diese maßnahmen umsetzen
und manches auch darüber hinaus auch
daran kann kein zweifel sein wir sind in
einer besseren situation ich will
drittens sagen ja wir können diskutieren
und streiten
und unterschiedliche vorstellungen haben
aber ich möchte doch ihr nochmal für uns
alle betonen diese entscheidung die
jetzt notwendig sind die trifft niemand
leichtfertig die kanzlerin hat gesagt es
gibt keinen tag an dem sie an dem uns
die existenzsorgen nicht umtreiben der
betriebe an dem uns auch die situation
in den familien nicht umtreibt das ist
glaube ich etwas was wir in aller
deutlichkeit betonen müssen und worauf
wir antworten geben müssen und ich bin
froh dass gestern genau diese dinge in
diesem beschluss auch sich wiederfinden
was die familien angeht da ist jetzt
eine diskussion beim können kitas und
grundschulen geöffnet werden aber es
wird festgehalten mit einem breiten
konsens es gibt eine priorität wenn
geöffnet werden kann
dann sollen kitas kindergärten schulen
die ersten sein diese priorität drückt
sich auch aus in der empfehlung in der
forderung die im freien folge so zu
verändern dass erzieherinnen und
erzieher das grundschullehrern und
grundschullehrer hoch gewertet worden
und es ist der konkret der ausdruck des
respekts dass wir haben von den
leistungen die diese menschen für unsere
gesellschaft in diesen tagen bringen
wirtschaftshilfen der herr lindner ist
es glaube ich nicht mehr da vielleicht
liest er gerade denn die ergebnisse des
koalitionsausschusses nach dann hätte er
gewusst hat er den verlust drückt
angesprochen hatte
sie wissen doch dass beschlossen wurde
den rücktritt von fünf millionen auf
zehn millionen euro zu erhöhen für ein
jahr
dadurch genau sie kennen ja die regelung
und ich bin ich verstehe dass sie sagen
es kann noch mehr werden
das ist ja in ordnung aber es ist eine
verdopplung es sind fünf millionen euro
mehr die zurückgetragen werden können
als zuvor und es ist sich nichts dann
ist ein wichtiger schritt genau so wie
es eine wichtige nachricht ist dessen
überbrückungshilfen drei jetzt beantragt
werden können
und wir setzen darauf dass die
abschlagszahlung die es möglich sind bis
zu einer höhe von 100.000 euro was auch
ein möglicher über ein wichtiger schritt
ist dass es ausgeschöpft wird dass es
schnell geht dass die länder die er die
auszeichnung machen
mit derselben intensität mit stärkerer
intensität wir alle als bisher daran
gehen die hilfen müssen schnell sein sie
müssen ausgeweitet werden das passiert
beim verlust rück trag- und sie müssen
noch besser abgestimmt werden und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass jetzt
mitgeteilt wurde dass die kfw das
kooperationsverbot aufhebt es
entschieden wurden zu recht im november
dass auch kleine betriebe die schnell
kredite haben können aber ein kleiner
betrieb der von anderen kredit hatte der
hat es nicht bekommt das ist es
aufgehoben alle betriebe in deutschland
können jetzt die schnell kredite
bekommen
das sind drei beispiele die dafür stehen
dass die hilfen verbessern wurden wir
müssen wenn die krise länger geht dieses
netz diesen instrumentenkasten weiter
ausbauen
darauf drängen wir und darauf arbeiten
wir hin da sind wichtige maßnahme ist
auf den weg gebracht werden und wir
bleiben dran glauben sie noch eine
zwischenfrage das gegeben
zum thema verlust drückt dann würde ich
gerne von ihnen wissen was ich sagen das
ist jetzt eine verdoppelung habe ich sie
entweder so verstanden diese
verdoppelung reicht jetzt aus oder habe
ich sie so verstanden dass es in der
koalition weitere überlegungen dazu gibt
hier auf den schon ursprünglich seit
mehreren monaten vorgesehen den
fdp-vorschlag zuzugeben wo ist da die
position ist das der punkt den sie jetzt
erreicht haben und für ausreichend
halten oder kommt da seitens der
koalition noch mehr
es ist ein wichtiger schritt in den ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender vorher vergessen
zu erwähnen
und ich wollte doch zur vollständigkeit
immerhin beitragen dass eine
verdoppelung 5 millionen auf 10
millionen ein erheblicher fortschritt
ist für den wir gekämpft haben und
richtig ist dass das haben sie
wahrscheinlich in den koalitionen in
denen sie mitgewirkt haben auch schon
erlebt dass man für dinge eintritt und
nicht immer auf einen schlag alles
erreichen kann was man möchte und
deshalb ist richtig dass wir das wissen
sie in der union für die erhöhung
eingetreten sind da haben einen
wichtigen schritt gemacht dass wir wie
sie ja auch der meinung sind dass es
richtig ist dass auch länger zurück
tragen kann sagt mal mit dem kollegen
rolf mützenich da ist es richtig dass
wir diese fragen gestellt
wir werden diese fragen auch weiter
stellen aber ich finde es gehört schon
auch dazu wenn man so eine debatte führt
dass man erkennt was fortschritte gibt
und eine verdopplung mit verlaub ist ein
erheblicher fortschritt erzielt vielen
dank herr kollege
letzte rednerin dieser debatte ist die
kollegin connemann cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der arme poet kaum ein bild wird so
verklärt der frierende künstler unterm
dach leider inzwischen nicht mehr nur
gemälde sondern realität der
künstlerinnen und künstler haben vor elf
monaten ihre existenzgrundlage verloren
und zwar von heute auf morgen
für sie bedeutet corona dauer lockdown
keine veranstaltung aufführung
ausstellung keine beschäftigung keine
einnahmen diese pandemie trifft kunst
und kultur wie eine naturkatastrophe
individuell aber auch
volkswirtschaftlich denn kultur und
kreativwirtschaft waren von corona kein
aschenputtel sondern ein
wirtschaftsfaktor mit einem stolzen
jahresumsatz von 170 milliarden euro vor
corona der rücklagen hatte hat diese
inzwischen aufgebraucht und zur
wirtschaftlichen not kommt sie ganz
große frage wann dürfen wir wieder auf
die bühne hinter die kamera zu unserem
publikum denn es geht nicht allein um
unsere künstler es geht um uns wir alle
brauchen kultur
denn sie ist systemrelevant und deswegen
verdienen künstler häfen und chancen
genau darauf haben wir reagiert an
erster stelle unsere
kulturstaatsministerin monika grütters
sie hatte die idee für ein einmaliges
programm neustart kultur es und fast
alle genre in stadt und land profis und
amateure
wir haben monika grütters dabei
unterstützt im sommer mit einer
milliarde und jetzt mit einer zweiten
milliarde für neustadt kultur ohne die
union hätte es diese verdoppelung
übrigens nicht gegeben für seine
initiative im koalitionsausschuss danke
ich unseren fragt
uns vorsitzenden ralph brinkhaus was
bedeutet neustart kultur
erstens rettung denn wir helfen bei
einnahmeverlusten und investitionen die
die pandemie erfordert zweitens zukunft
denn wir investieren in strukturen und
digitalisierung meine damen und herren
dabei geht es um mehr als 60
einzelbausteine in windeseile erarbeiten
mithilfe unserer kultur verbände für die
den ich im namen von cdu und csu
danke programme für musik galerien
theater tanz literatur buchhandlungen
bibliotheken museen film kino
soziokulturelle zentren und und und die
programme wurden maßgeschneidert und
kommen an 34.000 anträge 90 prozent der
mittel bereits belegt bundesweit das ist
grandios und mit der zweiten kultur
media.de können wir nahtlos weitermachen
und das ist gut
hinzu kommen gutscheines und für
veranstalter hilfen für kurz befristet
beschäftigte zukunftsprogramm kino und
und und rettung für viele
kultureinrichtungen und damit zukunft
auch für künstlerinnen und künstler
zukunft aber auch für unsere kultur
vereine vom heimatmuseum bis zum chor
denn die ehrenamtlich tätigen
profitieren ebenso von neustart kultur
hinzu kommt für ehrenamtlich tätige das
bundesprogramm ländliche entwicklung
aber auch hilfen der deutschen stiftung
für engagement und ehrenamt sonst würden
strukturen wegbrechen im ganzen ehrenamt
denn dieses lebt von der begegnung
und wenn diese fehlt lässt sich die
bindung und deshalb fördern wir als bund
das digitale miteinander denn wir wissen
jedenfalls als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
ohne ehrenamt ist kein staat zu machen
das gilt auch für unsere sportvereine in
denen sich über eine million menschen
ehrenamtlich engagieren als vorstände
als übungsleiter mit kreativen ideen
halten sie für 27 millionen mitglieder
auch in der pandemie derzeit
sportangebote aufrecht für jung und alt
und das ist schwerstarbeit
fakt ist mehr als die hälfte von ihnen
verlieren aber derzeit mitglieder und
beim mannschaftssport fehlen die
ticketeinnahmen in den ligen deshalb
haben wir ohne helfen auf den weg
gebracht und diese unterstützung kommt
bei den vereinen in der fläche an meine
damen und herren
corona trifft von der kultur bis zum
sport so unterschiedlich sie auch beide
sind beide brauchen hilfe und beide
bekommen hilfe damit wir sie auch noch
nach der pandemie haben denn sie sind
kein ornament sie sind das fundament auf
dem unsere gesellschaft steht und
deshalb ist es unsere aufgabe sie zu
sichern und zu stärken und genau dieser
aufgabe stellen wir uns in diesem haus
seit vielen vielen monaten gemeinsam
erfolgreich vielen dank frau coleen
könne man damit schließt sich die
aussprache
ich hoffe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 6
beratung des antrags der fraktion der
afg mit dem titel für eine
verfassungskonformen haushalt 2021
schuldenbremse einhalten abstrakte
normenkontrolle beim
bundesverfassungsgericht gemäß artikel
93 absatz 1 nummer 2 des grundgesetzes
wegen des gesetzes über die feststellung
des bundes haushaltsplans für das
haushaltsjahr 2021 für die aussprache
wurde eine dauer von 60 minuten
beschlossen wie ich bitte darum den
platzwechsel doch